all in all is actually kind of a weirdly
slow news day but we did have a lot of
news over the past weekend and for those
that missed it because you wouldn't it
was it was that was the intention of
Pfizer so that you would miss it last
Friday at 8 pm they issued their formal
response to James O'Keefe and project
Veritas okay informal they issued a
statement about mutations and directed
Evolution and the interesting thing is
that they actually said that in certain
cases such a virus could be engineered
so they could help help identify
antiviral drug treatments blah blah blah
basically in a matter of speaking they
made it seem like they were denying
having done anything like this it's not
getting a function of directed Evolution
nothing like that it's just engineering
such a virus and researching the
mutations to determine whether okay fine
you know what I don't know what they're
trying to say how about we read you
their statement which basically says
they're doing it and several outlets
have already reported they did not gain
a function but admit to
engineering viruses they claim it's safe
don't worry but we'll read into that
we'll talk about that plus we got
celebrity actor Zachary Levi Levy how do
you say Levi he's uh in Shazam and in
the wee hours of Sunday morning he
tweeted that he agreed Pfizer was
dangerous for the whole world and now
he's got a bunch of liberals attacking
him as an anti-vaxxer which is the
weirdest thing because he mentioned
vaccines nobody did it's just a big
Corporation that's been fined billions
of dollars for criminal uh for being
found guilty of criminal charges and
then allowed to continue operating so
we'll talk about all that plus a bunch
of really fun fun stuff you know CNN
record low ratings and uh apparently
signing Bill Maher it's not going to
save them but we'll talk about it before
we get started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work directly as a member click that
join us button you are supporting this
show the work we do you're helping make
it all happen and you also get access to
exclusive uncensored members only shows
uh from the Tim Sr podcast and we had
Stephen crowd around recently I would
definitely recommend checking that out
because he and I talk inside media
baseball and just generally about our
experiences with the media the things
they've offered us what it's like and
that I think is is really eye-opening
and a bit Evergreen if people ever
curious about how the media Works among
other things I mean a lot of jokes were
had but uh become a member and you'll be
supporting us and our cultural Endeavors
we're opening coffee shop coffee our
coffee brand should be launching very
very soon all we're waiting for right
now I think is The Organic certification
because it's a new label a new product
it is organic and so now the US
government has to tell you and to pay
them to tell you that it's true it is
organic so I guess it takes a long time
so anyway so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you really like it
click that share button and then share
it wherever and you can follow the show
at timcast IRL follow me at timcast
joining us today to talk about this and
a whole bunch more including his
personal experience the lockdowns we got
Matt Strickland
Tim thanks for having me on brother I
really appreciate it my name is Matt
Strickland and you uh you uh you're a
restaurateur I sure am before that uh I
uh I was in the military so I'm a
veteran it's been about 10 years of my
life fighting in Iraq and Afghanistan
and uh came home and I opened a food
truck it turned into a restaurant and
that quickly became successful as well
until covet hit and uh I realized very
early on that these mandates were more
about control than they were our health
and safety so I fought back and because
I fought back the government stripped me
of all of my licenses but I continued to
fight back and the people stood with me
and we kicked the government's ass you
won we won we got to talk about it this
is great we went down to gore melts in
uh it's in Virginia right uh amazing
food I love the music 90s music yeah it
was the food was legit it was good stuff
and uh and hearing that you you won in
the end is exactly what people need to
hear that's right because you know uh
non-violence of a disobedience a local
restaurant this is unconstitutional
we're going to do our thing the
government came after you it was a hard
fight and in the end you win that's it
that's what it was all about I mean I
saw them stripping my customers and my
employees of our constitutional rights
and I wasn't going to be complicit in
that and the reason was I spent my
entire adult life fighting dictatorships
overseas and I was not going to come
home to my country and allow a
dictatorship to rule and then what
disappointed me is that my Republican
leadership in the state of Virginia did
not step up and fight with me and for
that reason I'm now running for State
Senate in Virginia and I'm coming to
crush the establishment all right man
we'll we'll definitely talk about it
thanks for hanging out thanks for
joining us we got Libby hanging out as
well she's back hey what's going on it's
Libby Edmonds I'm with the
post-millennial glad to be here right on
hi everyone Ian Crossland here happy to
report bucko is doing extremely well we
had a amazing weekend together hanging
out healing eating a lot and also from
the front of gaming news if you haven't
heard Wizards of the Coast has gone back
on their decision and plans to basically
rip apart their old open gaming license
prioritize all their software they were
about to start taking huge chunks of
percentages from people that were trying
to make money off the DND rule set which
had previously been made open they
couldn't even do it they tried yeah and
they realized the CR the 89 of the
people were dissatisfied in their polls
so they just scrapped the whole plan
they're just keeping it open so another
another instance of humanity stepping up
and making sure that what's right
remains some quick context uh Mr bocus
is the cat he's our our cat here at the
at the cast castle and he's sex so Ian
is getting some experimental
experimental treatments for him but you
see for us normally you know bocus lives
with me or he did
um until Ian started attending to him
over the past couple of weeks for his
medicine but you know bogus will try and
wake us up at about 6 30 7 A.M screaming
and then what he does is he puts one paw
on your face and then lets out a claw a
d right in your face and you like wake
up twitch like a light like what's
happening and then he's yelling like I
want food wake up so we were thinking it
was kind of funny I'm like oh man you
know Ian sleeps so late how's he gonna
handle Boca screaming at him and then I
went Ian's awake at 6 30 a.m he goes to
the right bed so so bogus is chilling he
wants dinner Ian gives him his 6 30 a.m
dinner and then they both go to bed at
the same time it's great and also it's
Kara and I are doing it together my
girlfriend Kara so the two of us have a
12 hours on 12 hours off kind of
schedule the buckles in good hands right
on we got Serge pressing the Buns yo
what's up guys I hope you guys are well
it's been a long weekend for me but uh
we're out here let's get started all
right here's the story from the Daily
Mail Pfizer admits engineering coveted
mutants in lab studies to ensure its
antiviral drug works on new variants but
Pharma giant insists tests were not gain
of function and did not pose risk to the
public I love this story because like we
constantly hear this where it's like you
know the analogy I give is you know Dr
fauci is there a door on the building of
the niaid no there is no door we have no
door we have a pothole with a large
wooden object and there is a mechanic
mechanical device you twist which causes
it to unlatch and open on hinges and
you're like bro you're describing a door
they just play this game where they're
like I didn't jaywalk I just crossed the
street not in the crosswalk it's like
you're describing literally the thing so
Pfizer in response presumably to project
Veritas released a statement at 8 pm on
Friday look at this Friday January 27th
8 P.M you know we did a show that day
but like we didn't see this message come
out literally the moment we go live
because we we do pre-production about an
hour before
but we're gonna make sure we get this
story front and center on Monday so that
nobody forgets they try to memory hold
this let me read for you what they say
because uh it'll make you laugh
allegations have recently been made is
their statement related to gain of
function and directed Evolution research
at Pfizer and the company would like to
set the record straight
the next paragraph you're about to hear
is just patter to like make you not want
to read it they say in the ongoing
development of the Pfizer bio and Tech
covid-19 vaccine Pfizer has not
conducted gain a function or directed
Evolution research working with
collaborators we have conducted research
where the original SARS covet 2 virus
has been used to express the spike
protein from new variants of concern
this work is undertaken once a new
variant of concern has been identified
by public health authorities This
research provides a way for us to
rapidly assess the ability of an
existing vaccine to induce antibodies
that neutralize a newly identified
variant of concern we then make the data
available through peer-reviewed
scientific journals and use it as one of
the steps to determine whether a vaccine
update is required
okay so wait
you you get the new variance then you
test it see if you need to update makes
sense they add
in addition to meet U.S and Global
regulatory requirements for our oral
treatment Pax livid Pfizer undertakes in
vitro work EG in a laboratory culture
dish to identify potential resistance
mutations to nirma travel trailver one
of pax Levitt's two components with a
naturally evolving virus that is
important to routinely assess the
activity of an antiviral most of the
work is conducted using computer
simulations or of or mutations of the
main protease a non-infectious part of
the virus you see at this point I'm
reading it like they're not saying
they're engineering anything they're
then going to say in a limited number of
cases when a full virus does not contain
any known gain of function mutations
such virus may be engineered to enable
the assessment of antiviral activity in
cells okay
now they're just trying to play a legal
game with me let's just break that
sentence down to try and understand it
in in a limited number of cases when a
full virus does not contain any known
gain of function mutations
such virus may be engineered to enable
the assessment of antiviral activity in
cells what they're saying is when they
engineer the cell they need it to
express mutations like they said they
were checking for so that they can see
if their antiviral works that to me fine
don't call it gain of function call it
engineering like they did so covid's
actually engineering such a virus as
they've stated to assess antiviral
activity okay there you go
sorry
engineering but oh yeah Pfizer Pfizer
sorry yeah so Pfizer we're saying in
this they admit to engineering certain
viruses they said and then I have to
check and see if it works right right
it's not getting a function or directed
Evolution it's engineering what I I want
to go back this is the game they play
you're right Jim because when I read
this I also started to fall asleep after
especially after the second paragraph
where they're like let us be clear about
what we did we did not do it was the
first the way they start up the first
thing but when they say that they
they've conducted research where the
original SARS Cove 2 let me get this
blow this image up here
has been used to express the Sprite the
spike protein from new variants so the
original SARS cov2 virus has been used
to express the spike protein from new
variants what does that mean that that
just the use of hours to express a
protein in another variant well it just
sounds like what they're saying is
when there's a new variate discovered
they take it and then they
put it in a dish and like grow it so
they can have this micronism that that
doesn't sound like gain a function or
anything like that it's the bottom it's
the middle part of the third pair well
second paragraph where they're like and
in a limited number of cases if the
virus does not contain any known gain of
function mutations such a virus may be
engineered it sounds like they're saying
engineered to have gain a function
mutations it does sound like they're
saying that I think they are saying that
but you had uh you had fauci saying for
a while that they weren't doing gain of
function and then it was clear that the
research that was being funded was gain
of function research it says gain of
function on the research documents
that's what it said and Rand Paul is
like Dr fauci this this document is
yours and it says gain of function
research it no we did not do it it says
right here gain function I didn't do it
okay man I just and you can see why they
would think it's a good idea right you
can see why they would think like okay
we're gonna do research we're gonna
figure out you know we're gonna we're
gonna make the virus worse so that we
can test our drugs and whatever else you
can see why they think it's a good idea
but that doesn't make it
um untrue that they're doing it I
disagree I I think the potential
mutations of a virus have to be
what is this let's say there's there's a
million potential mutations to the virus
why would they mutate and be like if we
mutated it this way we can make a
vaccine for it this way it's like oh so
one in a million chance you make money
off that it doesn't make sense to me I
don't know to me it sounds like the
quintessential cya they just spent a
whole paragraph telling us they're not
doing something and just slipped the
sentence in there saying psych we're
doing it
I was saying before the show to you Matt
that like I think the uh maybe even have
like you know immunity from the CIA is
like go you're gonna have to lie on this
one and you've got all retroactive
immunity if it comes out that you were
lying in the future so I mean is public
information that Pfizer's got immunity I
mean and the reason they have immunity
is because our politicians aren't the
one running the show here guys and you
guys know that the people that are fun
in their campaigns are the ones running
their show and who's at the top of that
food chain Pfizer in the forms among
just massive people that print the money
basically who's making the money where's
the money coming from because those are
the people that are divvying out like
the federal decides who gets the loans
first right so you've got
um maybe a company that might sound like
black
Croc and I just said random word I
thought of and they get Federal Reserve
loans just pass right along to them to
buy up whatever they want companies like
these then uh you know I think we'll
invest in packs and super Pacs allowing
politicians to get elected I don't know
if um if overturning citizens united
ruling would actually change this it
might I'd be interested to hear what
people thought about that you guys are
familiar with citizens united yeah yeah
basically super Pacs as long as as long
as they don't collude with the candidate
they can they can you can they can
donate an infinite number of money and
then they can say whatever they want so
what ends up happening is you get big
corporations they'll go to the the
candidate and say are you the guy who's
going to help our very important
research save America because we're
looking to donate a lot to help that
happen and then the candidate will be
like well I don't know nothing about
that but rest assured I'm a big fan of
Pfizer and them helping would sure would
be great if I won and they go we get it
they then go to super back and say
Here's 500 million dollars we want him
Super PAC can run a campaign for
somebody you don't you have to be
involved in it they're going to make you
win well Biden is planning to completely
increase the medical induct industrial
complex as part of the cancer moonshot
plan
you know they're funding so they're
going to put so much money in to create
Federal
um like basically a
federally funded federally Affiliated
medical research situation wow that
sounds like a good idea it's disturbing
it's very disturbing yeah but that's
that's like part of their big plan
they're going to increase that portion
of the federal government get a whole
bunch of researchers on there to do you
know more stuff like this
um all in the idea that they're going to
cure cancer I wonder how much cancer
they make in Labs you know that they're
then going to try and cure it yeah well
I mean high acidity lymphatic system can
cause the cells to duplicate at a rapid
pace which a lot of scientists call
cancer like if you don't alkalize your
your lymphatic system
you can feed people sugar and keep
making medicine and then you're doubling
down on the profit because not only are
they buying your food they're buying
your medicine and I can't stand it I
think that there's some value for Pfizer
to be working on uh uh I guess you'd
call it
gain a function in simulations and
computer simulations like yeah quantum
computers
and billions of potential viral outcomes
and then millions and billions of
potential digital
you know cures a viruses in a computer
keep it in the computer because outside
you know they can leak they can leak
viruses can leak you create something
that you're afraid of becoming reality
you just created the thing that you were
afraid of becoming reality so I don't
know but I mean I think they're doing it
personally I think they're just doing it
for profit I think that companies
because they're allowed to if someone's
allowed to do something assume that
they're going to that if they're allowed
to make a virus and and a medicine for
it and profit off that medicine why
would they not well and once a once that
kind of technology or something like
that is created it will be used it's
just a matter of time the for-profit
aspect of it is is absolutely I mean
it's it's terrifying it's it's not
it's unethical it's a profit off of a
meta what the
I don't know people profit off of food
they profit off of food the food
industry is for profits so look man I've
never been all about laissez-faire
capitalism like Luke is you know he
likes to come on and he just talks about
how capitalism or free market solves
everything and this is corporatism and
things like that and the government
actually intervenes to help major
corporations win it's not really
capitalism but I genuinely believe that
if you have completely unrestricted
markets you're going to get seed oils
like this is my shout out to lukewar
change is you're not here to defend
yourself but too bad
unrestrained capitalism a company is
going to say look no one cares about
seed oils only these these weirdos like
Luke gradkowski are complaining about
seed oils and they're cheaper use those
but and then everyone's gonna start
eating them and if they get sick they're
not going to know why and there's not
going to be anything they're not they're
going to keep buying these products
um what really concerns me is the drug
dealers that are making money off this
system like Pfizer is a company that
deals drugs I mean you might use a
different term they sell drugs to people
but like the the tobacco industry used
to have commercials for kids they would
Target kids with Joe Camel and like they
want you to start early and that was the
Congress had to step in because the you
know unrestricted capitalism yeah you're
right about the drugs though and if you
look at the data the number of kids and
teens that are on psych meds
um is incredibly High and a lot of the
kids that are on psych meds are like
vulnerable kids like kids in foster care
a lot of boys are on psych meds and a
lot of these kids are on medications
that are not approved for their age
group and they're on multiple drug
cocktails that are not approved for
their age group as well I just want to
say stink bugs are lucky lucky they're
kind of cute and doofy they're not cute
I think they're they're tremendous
they're creepy they're not creepy
they're just like they they clap you
know that I don't like them they clap I
did it I I don't kill them but I also
don't like them you kill them they make
a stinky smell I don't want anything he
was he was on my monitor but uh they
clap I'm not even kidding I recorded a
segment and then I was done and I looked
up and it was a stink bug just going
like this like I'm like why is it what
is that like some kind of mating call
probably right I mean they were just
like yo you complained about Joe Biden
it's so good they danced too if you
watch them they'll like walk sideways
and then walk sideways and then keep
doing it like turn and shake and stuff
well as far as these uh pharmaceutical
companies go
this is saying to me how incentivized
doctors are to prescribe a certain
medication I was when I was in the
military I was a combat medic so I was
an infantry medic and the first job I
got when I got out of the military I was
working at a hospital and these
pharmaceutical reps would come in and
whine and die in these doctors and
provide all of us even us Medics you
know free lunches and such and uh and
it's just insane to me how incentivized
these doctors are to sell those specific
products and as far as the packs go they
may not be able to deal directly with a
with a candidate but everybody knows you
know if it's two or three people removed
they get a hold of these candidates and
I'm when Matt Gates was on the show just
a uh just a few days ago he told you
guys he said the first thing you do when
you become a congressman when you get to
DC is you sit down at a table with the
people who are the leaders in the
industry that you want to be a commit on
a committee of and uh and and that just
shows you right there it proves to you
how corrupt politics are and it lets you
know that these politicians that we get
pissed off at and that we blame for all
of these problems they're not the ones
running the show it's these lobbyists
and uh and these packs in the
pharmaceutical industry I mean those
guys are at the top of the top of that
food chain it's a lot of companies the
military industrial complex absolutely
Lockheed you got Boeing you got
Halliburton I mean the list goes on
Northrop what you were saying too about
um hospitals and pharmaceutical reps at
when I finished College I worked for a
uh like a small medical office and I was
like doing Insurance paperwork that was
my job but these pharmaceutical reps
would come in like almost every day and
they would bring lunch for the entire
office and they'd just like spill sample
cases full of their drugs all over the
place and it's so weird you're right
like they used to Target kids with
tobacco advertising and now like anytime
you watch TV there's half a dozen drug
advertisements and you listen to the
list and my son and I will joke about it
he'll be like oh this drug for
depression Mom it cures your depression
but you might have increased thoughts of
suicide and it's like oh okay isn't that
the opposite of what's supposed to do
and you listen to it and it's like this
will help you lose weight but you you
might want to kill yourself or sleeping
drugs and it says like you may forget
that you got up and drove your car while
you were on this drug so be careful with
that and why are we seeing all of these
um advertisements for major
pharmaceutical drugs that can make you
think you're sleeping while actually
you're driving your car the best thing
is uh when they don't actually tell you
what the drug does right and they never
do they're like ask your doctor and
you're like about what yeah I I remember
saying commercial I can't remember y'all
probably seen commercials like this
where it's like an old guy and he's like
looking sad and it's like the color's
gray and it's like feeling down maybe
Clovis stall is right for you and then
he's smiling and then he's like walking
through a park and it's like ask your
doctor today about clove vessel no I
don't know what you're selling me yeah
like the drug remains are so bizarre
like oh
to remedy the side effects from this
pill and then you need another pill to
rivet any side effects from that pill
and it just goes on and on and on and
that's why they created pill boxes this
one makes the pain go away but also
makes you want to die this one makes you
not want to die but could also make you
think about wanting to die so then you
have this one here that actually makes
you forget what's going on so that you
don't remember wanting to die side
effect it might cause pain so original
pill might have to double your
prescription you know I think when the
the oxycodone epidemic in the 90s late
90s this is the oxy this is the far this
is what you call the what would you call
it the what kind of drug is that it was
like an opiate I remember actually I was
trying to I was trying to buy weed and
uh the guy didn't have any weed and he
was like oh here take this and it wasn't
it was an oxycontin and I was I was out
for like two days let's look at that and
then you had no idea what it was that
you took it no yeah I was an idiot I was
an idiot obviously yeah we don't do that
nobody else should ever do that
especially with fentanyl people have
been dying from overdosing on fentanyl
that they think is like uh get the whole
fentanyl thing isn't it a prescription
drug like how did it get in all the
street drugs like how did this happen
prescription and Street no China I'll
tell you so in 2012 it is I had a
vasectomy in 2012. and first time I ever
took any kind of painkiller so they gave
me Percocet and Vicodin oh man that's a
lot of pain that's a lot of painkillers
powerful stuff I took two
and I flushed them down the toilet and
the reason I flushed them down the
toilet is because it was like the best
drunkness you've ever had without the
hangover and I was like this is
dangerous so I just I had to flush them
down the toilet and it's in the American
Water Supply because people are flushing
them down
but I I in 2014 I had a kidney stone and
there's something they can do for you I
mean if it's like really bad you might
get surgery but it wasn't really that
bad it just it hurts and also people
don't understand let me tell you guys
it's it's inside your body it's not like
you know you're going to the bathroom
one day and you're like there's
something jammed up in you know my my
schlong or something you're you're at
the doctors and it I'm like it's either
appendicitis or like they thought it was
appendicitis and then I went in like
pain in my abdomen and they're like yeah
it's your kidneys release like a small
rock and they're like nothing we can do
about it here's a bottle of pills and I
took one and you're you nailed it feel
awesome and and I never took another one
you wrote a song about it at least
that's one of the songs you were telling
me about it was that uh the guy
searching for the the fix at least that
was one that was written a long time
before that was wild but this is this is
uh like the feeling you get from it was
so intense that I did same thing you did
yeah I didn't push on the toilet I just
threw it away but the point is that so I
flush it down the toilet and I just took
Motrin and guess what I was absolutely
fine that's all I needed so these
doctors they're just pushing this
medication just shoving it down your
throat well it's not only the medication
it's surgery it's like at one point I
hurt my back like after my son was born
and I saw two doctors and they were like
you need back surgery and I was like no
no I do not need back surgery look at
Hulk Hogan he's paralyzed now right yeah
we were just talking about it before the
show I had a doctor I went in because I
was having trouble sleeping and she
prescribed me sleeping pills which then
gave me nightmares and I also couldn't
sleep and then I bought new pillows like
I literally bought new pillows and I
didn't have an issue ever like ever
after that you know the reason I brought
up the opiate crisis and some people
call it epidemic because is do you see
what the Sackler family did to humanity
for profit in the 90s and in the 2000s
crazy so that's the example of what
pharmaceutical companies all over
everything I know you would think at
this point people would realize oh that
family is demonic I'm not like a good
and evil kind of guy I'm not that binary
but when you see pharmaceutical
companies eradicating the population for
profit I gotta wonder if maybe they're
evil or doing so
oxytocin it's supposed to be like a
feel-good chemical like oxide because
oxytocin is like I think that's why they
named it it's like the orgasm
manipulation tactics thing so you would
think people would be so awakened to the
pharmaceutical company's attempt at
profits that they would be eye-opening
and gazing at Pfizer right now like with
a microscope what's weird is they came
down so hard on Tobacco right but they
don't come down they like praise the
pharmaceutical industry for all that
they're doing for Humanity and the
pharmaceutical industry is getting all
this Federal funding
right you know hey burning burning
breathing and burning smoke it obviously
is bad for you so that's an easy target
paying up for that stuff with like all
the covet tests and all that crap
considering we're ragging on uh these
big pharmaceutical Pharmaceuticals let's
jump to this story from Fox News Zachary
Levy Sparks Twitter controversy over
claim that Pfizer is a danger to the
world hardcore degree hardcore agree I
love this here's a tweet Lyndon wood
said do you agree or not that Pfizer is
a real danger to the world he said
hardcore agree and uh liberals went nuts
okay one less movie ticket to ticket to
spend money on stupid
seriously guy like he he does he didn't
like a massive multinational
pharmaceutical Corporation that's been a
fine some of the largest fines in
history 2.3 billion plus another 430
million from four uh five years prior
they didn't learn their lesson they got
fined like 200 million and I think it
was in 2001 or something like that they
got fined 430 million 2004
then they got fined again in 2009 and it
was 2.3 billion dollars and my question
is at a certain point why not just shut
them down you're committing crimes over
and over again you're done when a human
being commits a crime we say we take you
from your job your job is no longer
being done we put you in a box we close
it you can't go out oh these
corporations well it depends on the
severity of the crime sure but if we're
talking about a crime against you many
on the scale of 2.3 billion dollar fine
because they were selling off you know
off I I can't remember exactly what they
were what they were doing but they were
like
misleading the public as to what their
drugs were doing or something like that
well they let you know how crooked it is
because at my restaurant if there was
case after case after case after case of
people getting sick after eating at my
restaurant I'd be shut down and there'd
be no question about it if if if you ran
a company if you were if you're in a
restaurant
and that restaurant was dealing drugs
out of the back door they would shut it
down every employee fired I mean it's
like sorry this company is doing
committing crimes that's right and and
you know what it could be it could be
one manager who's been doing it and they
shut the thing down and they say no no
this is this is a criminal Enterprise
and then the people are just like I
don't know man I just make burgers like
too bad you lose your job but when a
pharmaceutical company does it this is
the reality of the world they're too big
to fail so the government says just give
us a cut of the profit and keep doing
what you're doing so for the record
Pfizer got fined 2.3 billion uh for
misbranding bextra with the drug bextra
with the intent to defraud or mislead
the attempt essentially according to
extra four justice.gov
um I'm not sure hold on was that is that
the 2.3 million 2.3 billion they were
selling it off label meaning that they
didn't get FDA approval for The Things
They were selling it for they had only
had approval for the original thing and
they actually the FDA had declined to
give it approval for the things that
they were selling it for off the label
according to justice.gov
a big big big mishandling well there's a
public trust there's also a situation
where this there's this drug Lupron
that's used for um for uh like prostate
cancer and things like this
um and it's being used off label as a
drug to give children to block puberty
to for gender dysphoria and it's also
used for precocious puberty in a few in
like some cases but it's only
recommended for three months at a time
and so it's not approved for uh you know
it's not FDA approved for use in
children for more than three months for
this extra purpose this gender dysphoria
purpose but no one says anything about
it and lupron's sales continue to
increase
they don't recommend the drug for that
purpose but they certainly just keep
taking the money this company ABV which
is just a ton of drugs this is what this
is how it works with big corporations
typically the government just says look
give us our cut and you can keep doing
it a company does something that's
illegal makes 10 million dollars FTC
says it's a five five million dollar
fine sir and they go oh oh geez oh I
guess I gotta pay you have a nice day I
put five million in their pocket I
should specify assists here that the FDA
uh when it came to bextra specifically
declined to approve so I think that they
didn't say this is bad I think they just
didn't give it an approval but they want
to post it anyway Zachary Levy is it
Levi is it Levy is it Levy do now I'll
call him Levy he uh was getting ragged
on and attacked by the left so he
tweeted just one example of what I'm
referring to and it's at justice.gov the
largest what is the largest Health Care
fraud settlement in history it's not
anymore I think there's a was a
glaxosmith clients now the biggest yeah
three three billion something but uh and
that was later on but they're still
attacking this guy over it's like
you're not gonna go see Shazam next I'm
you know what I'm do I'm gonna buy two
tickets to Shazam
and if nobody takes it just just pay for
it just I'm gonna I'm gonna give the mat
that the DC Universe Warner Brothers
money because they they got a guy
leading a movie who didn't say anything
anti-vaxx just said hey man be wary of
these massive multinational corporations
they're dangerous I respect that
and that's the kind of marketing I think
movie should be all about so you know
I'll buy two two tickets two tickets for
you thanks okay I won't see it but yeah
okay oh maybe I will then oh we got
tickets to go oh no we don't have
tickets we have tickets to see Quantum
Mania I'm no I I really do want to see
it's a Shazam Fury of the Gods I'm
really excited the first Jam was Shazam
was awesome I don't know anything about
Shazam it's uh DC Superhero Billy
Batson's a little kid wizard gives him
the power of uh Shazam a bunch of gods
Shazam is that like the wisdom of
Solomon the strength of Hercules the the
you know something I don't know he's
always he's a little kid and then he
yells Shazam and gets struck by
lightning and then turns into a big huge
dude and it's it's fun and funny it was
like the only DC movie that was actually
a bit irreverent I like the funny ones
that's why I liked Guardians of the
Galaxy yes it's funny you'll like you
haven't seen Shazam you'll like it no
I'll check it it's fun can I take my kid
probably oh yeah absolutely she'll be
like oh nice we're getting to see
something I like but you can see the
first one the first one's out okay it
was like the best performing DC movie I
think because they're all garbage this
one actually was good and uh the second
one's coming out and all these Liberals
are yelling like one month before the
movie comes out this guy's an
anti-vaxxer and it's like you didn't say
any of that you guys are nothing is like
these Hollywood people they need you all
to comply with their Viewpoint or else
they're gonna yell at you and it's like
there's no reason to comply with
anyone's Viewpoint think for yourself
every single time I mean obviously it's
like making a song this is why the
Beatles were so great John and Paul did
not work in lockstep they didn't know
they didn't sing harmonics of their
words they sang two totally different
songs together to create a mega song and
we need more of that who do you think
better John or Paul John really I mean
my John Lennon's one of my ultimate
personal top three Heroes well here's
the here's the words Washington and
Einstein probably Paul was Poppy John
Lennon was cool and so together that was
that was a you know powerful that was
the that was the force John's willing to
speak out against the military
industrial complex before it was good I
mean he had the cool glass think about
like Paul's songs with like what was
that was that one he wrote years ago
everything's gone so many
it's all like super it is very poppy
yeah he was the pop star of the band and
John Lennon is all like Vietnam is wrong
you know kids are getting dark angry got
beat up when he was a kid like just a
rough life love that guy do you know
what I want to add some Nuance to what
um Zachary was saying about Pfizer being
evil I think that what happens is
unfettered drug dealers are dangerous or
evil not not all not because marijuana
is a different Beast if uh caffeine is a
different piece they're both drugs THC
and yeah unfettered it's really bad I
mean like there's unfettered marijuana
sales in New York City right now you
can't walk down the street without
smelling it like every Bodega has
unregulated marijuana sales you don't
have any idea what is being purchased or
what is being sold you don't have to
show ID there's absolutely no regulation
and the city is trying to shut it down
now and be like no we're only gonna give
weed licenses to people who were
formally incarcerated or you know from
on drug charges but it's been like over
a year you can't you can't tell the
bodegas they have to stop selling loose
pre-rolled joints now they're not going
to
um and it's it's unregulated it's
unfettered and it's not a good thing
yeah Pfizer is a result of an unfettered
like a a system where they can have
immunity like modern is right there in
the shadows if you want to take down
spend in the next 10 years taking on
Pfizer moderna is next and it's gonna be
the exact same problem it blows my mind
that there's regular people on Twitter
defending Pfizer I can't believe that I
mean it's it's the same it's the same
other people well yeah probably not but
it's the same cycle when it comes to
these pharmaceutical companies it's
creative medicine or vaccine or whatever
cause injuries destroy lives make 30
billion dollars find three billion
dollars rinse and repeat well that's the
thing I was saying about what we were
just reading with the off label the
intentional misleading these are these
are companies that uh if you pull up
there's the Wikipedia list of all of the
crimes committed by these corporations
so the the real issue for me is
these people aren't doctors I mean
they're technically doctors but you know
but you have a doctor that you talk to
when you're like yo I got a bum knee
they know your medical history they know
your family if you get a good one you've
had them for a long time the problem is
when you mentioned earlier they go and
Lobby the doctors and they say I I told
this story uh earlier I was skating when
I was like 16 and I hit my knee and I
heard it and I'm like I better get it
checked out doctor says nah it's a
sprain or a strain or something you're
fine here and then he handed me a whole
bunch of sample packets of an
anti-inflammatory steroid
methylprednisolone I think it was my
goodness and he was like just take a
couple of these and there were sample
packs and he just threw them at me and
then I was like whatever you say Doc and
I'm like my actor did that with birth
control pills like in little sample
packs yeah like a ton of them like here
just take all these you know this is my
family's doctor and when I was 16. and
you when you know what ended up
happening is I I was like okay so he's
like I took a couple of them and then I
didn't notice anything and the next day
I was like I don't know I just didn't
take them and then I ended up just
getting better because I was a kid who
yeah I banged my knee I was skating I
fell hit my knee and I couldn't bend it
and so it like swole up or something it
turned out to be nothing legitimately
serious or anything like that but
I just kind of I don't know man it's
kind of weird to me
you gotta you gotta make sure you got a
good trusted doctor it's just that you
got to make sure that when they when
they hand you some like samples or
whatever you ask them what is it what
does it do why do I need it and if they
can't answer and they're like well it
was given to me then maybe you got a
Salesman and not a doctor so find
someone who can give you good advice and
talk to you about it but actually uh
Matt I wanna I wanna talk to you about
what what you went through because you
know we're talking about this Farm all
the big Pharma stuff
but I'm curious when all the lockdowns
happened there were a handful of
businesses that stood up and said no
what you you ran one of these businesses
that the government
tried to shut down you resisted and the
first thing I just want to say is this
is a story that I'm excited for you to
tell because we've long told people
non-violence of a Disobedience stand up
what you believe in file the lawsuits
file the complaints make them work for
their their oppression or whatever and
you will win and you won they try to
shut you down they they hurt your
business they hurt you but then in the
end you ended up winning out so let's uh
tell us exactly what went down with your
business how that how that started yeah
well so as soon as coven start I was
actually at the at the time I was still
working as an intelligence analyst for
the military just to supplement my
income you know because when you when
you start a restaurant you're not Off to
the Races you know automatically making
money
so when covet happened in March of 2020
they shut my entire program down that I
was working on and I was working on a uh
a pretty intense a pretty serious
program and uh that had a lot of
National Security implications so when
they sent all of us home and they shut
the entire skiff down I paid attention
and I said well this must be something
serious this must be a virus that's
going to kill half the world like
they're saying so I took it serious and
uh I I listened to the recommendations
of at that time Governor Northam and I
shut my restaurant down took a step back
because I wanted to be responsible and
didn't want to put my customers In
Harm's Way nobody knew at that time what
was going on so
it wasn't long after that maybe a month
or so that I started to realize
something weird was going on and then
three months after June of 2020 Governor
Northam said okay restaurants you can
open back up but under these provisions
and that's when it clicked I said wait a
minute
this is more about control than it is
our health and safety and it was because
they put mandates in place like you have
to wear a mask when you walk in the
restaurant but as soon as you sit down
somehow you're safe from covid and
nobody's allowed to sit at my bar but I
can pull the table up to the bar and uh
you can sit there and my bartender
couldn't hand the drink over the bar my
bartender had to walk around the bar and
serve it to the person side by side just
very arbitrary uh mandates that made
absolutely no sense and uh so like I
said I spent my entire adult life
fighting dictatorships overseas and I
wasn't going to come home and allow a
dictatorship to rule so I did the only
thing I could do and that was fight back
by not complying Civil Disobedience and
I kind of
did that kind of under the radar uh at
first I didn't announce it my customers
just knew that when they came to gore
melts they were walking in to uh what
America used to be pre-coveted they were
walking into Freedom a safe space a safe
space there you go and uh and I operated
that way actually from June of 2020 to
January of 2021. I would get a call from
uh from the health department maybe once
a month or so and they would say hey
Matt we uh we got a call from one of
your customers that said you're not
following covet mandates and I would
never confirm or deny it and at that
time the Health Inspectors they weren't
allowed to come out and inspect so none
of them ever came came out to my
restaurant so I would just say oh well
thanks for the call I appreciate that
and they would just say oh yeah you know
just you know follow covet mandates and
I'm like okay cool whatever
and uh and it went like that until
January 2021. now what happened in in
January was Biden took office
and when he took office as you guys know
he started firing off all of these
executive orders one of those executive
orders mandated OSHA come out in
conjunction with local Health
departments and shut down restaurants
specifically that weren't following
covet mandates and that's when I got my
first visit from the the health
department and OSHA
and they said hey Matt you're not
following coven mandates and I said no
no I'm not I said because they don't
make any sense I said if you can make
them make sense to me common sense
because I'm all about common sense I
I've never been a very political guy
I've never trusted politicians on either
side of the aisle to be honest with you
and uh and and I just want things that
make sense and what he told me is really
what set the wheels in motion he said
well Matt it doesn't have to make sense
the governor said you have to do it so
you have to do it and at that point I
said absolutely not this is not how
things work in America
and he said well we'll come back and uh
we'll suspend your your health
department license and I said well you
do what you have to do but I'm going to
do what I know I have to do and uh and
that is afford my customers their
constitutional rights and at that point
I told him I said at this point you were
trespassing so if you don't leave my
property I'll have you removed any left
but he he made good on his promise and
he came back about two weeks later
served me with the suspension papers
suspended my health department license
and in the state of Virginia
if your health department license is
suspended your alcohol license your ABC
license is automatically suspended so I
lost both of those that day
and I continued to to operate business
as usual I didn't comply and at that
point I made a video and uh and I put it
out to the public what was going on and
I let them know that I would not be
compliant and uh the main reason is
because like I said before spent a lot
of my time a lot of my adult life
fighting overseas and I have a lot of
brothers that went overseas with me and
didn't make it back a lot of guys that
died over there and their kids are
growing up right now here in the United
States of America because they felt that
America was more important than their
life so if I'm not willing to put my
livelihood on the line when those guys
were willing to put their life on the
line then what kind of man am I and my
wife and I we always teach our kids to
do what's right no matter what the
personal cost is to them so how in the
hell are we going to teach them that if
we're not willing to do the same thing
ourself so those are the main reasons
why I fought back and because I did that
uh they they sued me Governor Northern
sued me and he took me to court and
tried to shut my business down but I
didn't back down and it was overwhelming
the response from the community that
showed up after that I mean I had people
coming from Across the Nation to support
me I had one guy come all the way I
remember from Iowa
now my restaurant gourmeltz is right off
of Interstate 95 in Virginia not even a
mile from the exit so it's uh it's very
convenient so I get a lot of people that
come by all the time just passing
through so this guy came up to me and uh
he said hey I'm from Iowa and I said
well you just passing through or what
and he said nope I flew out here just to
come to your restaurant and shake your
hand and look you in the eye and thank
you for what you were doing and he
started crying and and that right there
Amanda got me it let me knew it let me
know at that point that I was doing the
right thing because when you make a
decision like my wife and I made which
was to fight back
you know you have no idea which way it's
going to go uh we thought it was going
to be the end of uh of our business we
thought it was going to be at the end of
everything we worked our entire life for
but the community showed up and they
supported us and we had a line out the
door from open to close and by 7 PM we
had no food left wow all we had was
bread and people were walking up to the
register saying give me a piece of bread
and I'll pay full price for it wow it's
amazing and it just it blew my mind and
uh and we continued to fight back and uh
and I reached out to my my uh my
Republican representatives in Virginia
because they're supposed to be
conservative Patriots that stand for the
Constitution and all I was doing was
standing for the Constitution standing
for my customers constitutional rights
and uh and I was very disappointed that
none of my Republican Representatives
reached back out to me
and so
long story short I I said how do I get
rid of these scumbags how do I make sure
because they run around saying Democrats
are ruining the country and they are
but these Republicans that are sitting
on their hands not willing to step up
and fight for you and me they're no
better than those Democrats that's the
establishment we talk about the unit
party is absolutely real
in the end you end up you got your back
your liquor license your health license
and all that stuff well so so what
happened is uh we go to court for with
the health department
and uh and I beat the health department
in court I proved that these mandates
were in fact unconstitutional and they
had to give me my health department
license back good so the next step was
uh the ABC we go before the ABC Board to
get my abc license back and we thought
it would be you know cut and dry open
and shut hey you took my abc license
only because the Virginia Department of
Health took my health department license
well we beat them in court and they had
to give me that license back so now in
turn you should have to give me my abc
license back makes sense right yeah
well it's a very liberal ABC Board now
at this time we had a change of
Governors in Virginia
uh so Governor younke took over so now
Ralph Northam is no longer the uh the
governor
uh we got a republican governor
Republican lieutenant governor and
Republican Attorney General
so I go before the ABC Board and it's a
very liberal ABC Board and what they
said was in a nutshell basically was
Matt didn't matter that you beat the
Department of Health and that's the only
reason we took your license it doesn't
matter that the reason they took it was
unconstitutional all that matters is we
took it and you didn't comply and that
word comply kept coming up and they said
so for that reason we're not going to
give you your license back and I said
well Roger that then I don't need a
license and I continue to sell alcohol
without it wow and I immediately as soon
as uh Glenn younke took office I reached
out to him and I heard nothing back from
him we all saw the video where you're
filming and the ABC guys come in and the
cops come in and they're they're raiding
and looting your private property of
alcohol what so what finally happened
what is this yeah well the reason they
came out and raided my place is because
like I said I was reaching out to the
governor since uh he took office and by
that time I announced my run for state
senate to uh come crush the
establishment and Republican leadership
they don't like when a republican
candidate speaks out against other
Republicans but uh I have no idea why
you should speak out against any
politician that's not doing their job so
for that reason they didn't reach out
and help me they left me to the wolves
and I heard nothing back from the
governor's office or the Attorney
General's office until December 2nd of
2022 this past December when the
Virginia State Police and the Virginia
ABC agents came and raided my restaurant
and took every drop of alcohol out of my
restaurant that's where you're at right
now what well so that's the viral video
that uh that you guys saw and and so
what happened after that is uh
we were going back and forth and they
were trying to settle with me but I've
always stayed strong in my stance and
that I will not settle with you I didn't
do anything illegal I didn't do anything
wrong what what settled what kind of
settle do they want at this point I mean
the whole thing's over yeah well so you
know they've always you know they they
were offering me you know hey Matt
instead of 90 days of suspension and a
fifteen thousand dollar fraud or
whatever it was uh no suspension of your
license and just give us two thousand
dollars oh my goodness little extortion
a little Shakedown yeah exactly and it's
all about them wanting to get a win and
that's it and uh so I said listen I
stood strong paid no settlement at all
and they kept coming back with
settlement office settlement I said you
know what I will settle with you
I said I'll pay you 17.76
and I was hoping like hell they took
that just to remind them of Freedom this
is like Michael Corley Corleone when he
says you know my office I offer is this
nothing that's right so of course they
didn't take it and uh
and I said well listen man you guys
aren't getting a dime from me
I am not going to serve a suspension and
I'll tell you what
after I reopened my restaurant for
Christmas because I'll be closed for
Christmas when I reopen after Christmas
I'm gonna open my bar back up and I'm
gonna sell alcohol and I'm operating
business as usual
and magically before I close for
Christmas December 23rd and I told him I
said Hey listen if uh if Glenn yakin and
uh and and the rest of the Republican
leadership in Virginia if you guys are
ready for the political storm that
follows you arresting a small business
owner who's also a veteran that fought
for his country if you're ready for that
political shitstorm I'm ready to go to
jail because a lot of my brothers were
ready to die for this country and they
did so I've been ready to die from my
country since I was 17 years old so I'm
I'm damn sure ready to go to jail for my
country so at that point it was uh it
was a Mexican standoff man and uh and
they folded December 23rd they gave me
all of my alcohol back they gave me my
abc license back and I didn't pay a dime
when did we go down there what was that
that was before this right that was
before that so you remember we were
planning a party right right yeah so I I
told you I said hey Tim this is my plan
I said regardless of what happens the
the day we open after Christmas we're
going to be selling alcohol man let's
throw a party down here and we were
planning that yeah and uh and magically
they uh they said uh you know what never
mind they tapped out and they said uh
they brought your booze back December
23rd you get everything back yeah wow
well you would have made them look so
bad yeah I mean you made them look bad
and good what yeah very what happened
like in the early days when you were
resisting the initial stuff what was the
process day one you didn't shut down
were they like finding you every day and
then and in retrospect they just
dismissed the fines what was happening
day to day yeah I feel other people are
going through this yeah I mean it was it
was so I was fined over seventy thousand
dollars by OSHA for having an unsafe
work environment was that a day by day
fine that added up it was just arbitrary
fines that they just made up so like
they sent me this piece of paper that
said oh hey Matt uh for not making
people wear a mask we're finding you
twenty thousand dollars for not putting
up Plexiglas we're finding you thirty
five thousand dollars or whatever it was
where the hell did you get that where'd
you get those numbers from where you
just made them up and where'd you get
these regulations yeah I mean they're
totally arbitrary plexiglass is gonna do
something yeah it's just insane so when
when that ocean inspector actually came
out to my restaurant he said you got to
put plexiglass up I said Okay I want to
know the regulation
how wide does the Plexiglas have to be
and he said well actually in the
regulation there's nothing that says how
wide it has to be I said well so you're
telling me if I put a one inch strip of
plexiglass up I'm technically in
compliance and they said well yeah
technically yeah
and I said listen man take your OSHA hat
off for one second and just talk to me
man-to-man does that make any sense to
you and again he said Matt it doesn't
have to make sense that's what they said
so you have to do it and uh psychotic
that's not how the American government
is supposed to work that's how they work
that's how they do it and so we signed
up for what my story proves what it
proves is that if you stand up and you
fight back no matter how much they try
to back you into a corner and bully you
if we stand together because I wouldn't
have won this by myself it was just me
Matt Strickland fighting I'd be in
prison right now but the people of
America stood with me from Across the
Nation I mean they came out of the
Woodworks and supported me and the only
thing that politicians the only thing
that they answer to is political
pressure and uh I mean everybody knows
Glenn young is trying to run for
president now and so they inundated his
office with emails and phone calls he
couldn't make a social media post
without somebody jumping on his post
saying hey what about Matt Strickland
what about gourmetz and uh and they came
to that political pressure they didn't
want to help me because I stand up
against not only Democrats but
Republicans also but the the political
pressure was enough from across the
nation that they had no choice but to
act I think part of what's what's what's
great about the story is too you were
willing to comply in the early days in
the very beginning when you didn't know
if it was Airborne Ebola where people
were gonna their skin was gonna start
melting off you didn't know and you were
ready to make the sacrifice for the
betterment of the people and then when
the evidence starts coming in then then
you're it's like okay now realism and
Common Sense takes over as it did in the
beginning too I think that's why I was
willing to shut down for two weeks but
to slow the spread but yeah on top of
that it's you you'd walk into a
restaurant
and they would you'd walk in the front
door and they would say please put on a
mask you'd say okay you put it on they'd
hand hand you one right you'd wear it
and they say now the chair right next to
you please sit and take the mask off
right then you take it off throw in the
garbage and then you're supposed to put
it back on to walk to the bathroom do
you remember this you were supposed to
put it back onto it we had a we had a
plan here we never got around to because
you know in West Virginia it was fairly
lacks and then they ended up lifting it
but what we wanted to do is get full
hazmat suits nice walk in sit down take
the full suit off
you know like go to your table take the
full suit off place it on the chair next
to you sit down order food and then go
I'm gonna run to the bathroom real quick
put the full suit back on zip it up and
then walk slowly and awkwardly just to
make the point yeah it's like there's
that comic where the person's walking in
the covet virus hits him in the face and
that shows I'm sitting down with like a
green
exactly well and it's interesting too
how you talk about how it was June 2020
that they said you could open your
restaurant again and they hit you with
all of these arbitrary arbitrary
restrictions of what you had to do in
your restaurant that's of course after
George Floyd was killed and it was after
the entire government of all the blue
States decided that um you can't get
covet if you're protesting for black
lives matter but you can get covet if
you go to a restaurant that doesn't have
plexiglass you know what you should have
done you should have just put up a BLM
flag
and then they'd say you know what you're
good no fine for you they would have
been okay with that yeah I mean it's
funny you guys say that because
of course I was trashed online for not
following coven mandates and people who
have never met me a day in my life uh
were saying all kinds of things about me
and somehow just because I didn't make
people wear a mask when they walked into
my restaurant I was racist
I knew I knew that was coming too it's
always it's always racist whatever
whatever when you don't comply when you
don't just do what you're told then
you're racist as though as though
there's all these you know as though
there's no black people who want to
stand up for their rights it feels like
aliens are trying to control us but
don't quite understand humans like well
humans don't like being called racists
so no matter what they do call it
racists is like andraelis on Aliens it's
children it's it's you know you know the
best part about the internet is on the
internet you you're not aware you're
arguing with a 14 year old yeah they're
adult men
in their 40s who work for major news
outlets who go on Twitter and there's an
account called like you know Trump Maga
300 and it'll be a picture of trump
going like yeah and then it'll say
something like you're stupid your
politics are bad and they'll be like who
is this guy you're so you can't say that
to me and it's like a 14 year old kid is
just laughing I have no idea what's
going on he's like they could even be
11. it could be like 11 year old kid it
could be my kid yeah just goofing off on
the internet don't even care these
people take it so seriously I had so one
of my uh the DDM on my team in Iraq the
sniper he uh when we'd have down time
he'd go on and play Call of Duty and uh
I remember when he told me one one
morning he was he was arguing with like
a 12 year old on Call of Duty who he
showed me crazy look at this dude look
what he's saying man you suck you have
no idea what real Combat is you don't
know how to shoot that's what the kid
was saying to him the dude is a sniper
you know what I mean you know looking
back over the last couple years for
yourself is there anything that you
would have done or or would change have
changed in the process I know it seems
to have turned out extremely well but
for people in the future that are
willing to stand up you know and prevent
to create Civil Disobedience yeah watch
is there anything that you can help with
yeah well first of all
what I would have done earlier is pay
attention to politics I I uh I did not
pay attention to politics like I do now
and uh and I run it for state senate now
and if anybody wants to follow my
journey on that um they can follow me on
social media at Matt for VA
um and my website's matt4va.com if you
want to see how that turns out but I'm
ashamed to say and I was telling you
guys this before the show the first time
I ever voted was in 2020 and the reason
for that is because I don't trust
politicians on either side of the aisle
and so pay attention to politics
especially on the state level because
that's where you make your money but as
far as fighting against coveted mandates
and such I truly believe it'll happen
again maybe not in the same shape and
form that happened this last time but
the government trying to take control of
our rights I mean so what are the
mandates in Virginia was you weren't
allowed to leave your house between the
hours of midnight and 5 a.m how is that
curbing covid how does that do anything
remember the guy on the beach he was
arrested for surfing by himself remember
the video where the guy's jogging in the
beach and the cop chases after him and
the jogger just speeds up yeah he just
bolts and the cop can't catch him it's
just insane that sounds more like an
anti-rioting thing yeah it just makes no
sense so what I would say is what you
need to do the next time something
doesn't feel right is trust your gut and
you need to stand up and you need to
fight back from the beginning and not
only that
everybody needs to support you
especially small business owners you
would be surprised how many
restaurateurs in the state of Virginia I
had called me as soon as they heard
about my story and they would say hey
Matt thank you so much for standing up
and doing what you're doing I'm totally
behind you 100 what can I do to support
you and I would tell each and every one
of them if you believe in what I'm doing
the best thing you can do to support me
is do the same thing and they would all
say the same thing they wouldn't do it
not me I don't want the health
department breathing down my neck man
and I said listen
with that attitude they're going to be
breathing down your neck the rest of
your life man well wasn't that the
shocking thing too was how many people
just did comply it was I I found that so
stunning how many Americans just sucked
it up and did what they were told and I
found that extremely disappointing for
my fellow countrymen to watch them just
like capitulate and do what the
government told them to do it's like
that's not what we're founded on we're
founded on telling the government
exactly that we're not going to do what
they tell us to I feel like video games
has made people really willing to comply
because in a game there's a structure
and a set of rules that you cannot
bypass you're stuck within yeah yeah
this this realm if then but in reality
you have complete Freedom you can do any
go anywhere see anything interact with
anything I just started watching have
you guys seen 1883 negative I haven't
seen Yellowstone but uh we're having
dinner and everyone's like you got to
watch it 1083 songs
and uh there's there's a really great
scene where
the uh there's like it's a bunch of
German people and they're trying to get
to Oregon because it's Paradise they
hear
and they they gotta cross a river and so
the you know the Marshall guy or
whatever his name is he's like you guys
uh swim in Germany I was like no it's
illegal and he's like it's illegal to
swim in German Germany and then he gets
angry and he's like everything I don't
think he says Germany says it's illegal
to swim where I'm from it's like
everything is illegal where I'm from
like that's why we're leaving and it's
it's crazy to think about that that's
for a lot of people
that we're leaving Europe and coming to
emptiness conflict and death it was
because it was better than having the
government live to live with the
government's boot on your neck I
actually just showed uh my son the other
night the movie Brazil you remember that
movie
it's I think it's Terry Gilliam is that
that's a person right I'm pretty sure
it's his movie but um it's basically
it's about this guy who works for the
government and it's just all red tape
and bureaucracy and all he does he has
his he has his dreams you know and he
like lives in a fantasy kind of but at
the end at a certain point we'll give it
away but he ends up
um sort of outside of the city he ends
up away from the paperwork and you just
see this these mountains and you're just
you could it's like you can finally
breathe watching the movie we're doing a
whole dystopia thing right like he's
reading 1984. we're gonna we're gonna do
all of it Fahrenheit 451 but the other
thing that you were talking about in
terms of the covert restrictions and how
that was used and these restaurant tours
are going to have the government
breathing down their necks the rest of
their lives there's a lot of officials
around the world not necessarily in the
U.S although I think probably in the
byte Administration there are who see a
lot of this coved lockdowns and
restrictions almost as a blueprint of
how they can
um coerce the population into submitting
to climate change mitigation measures
the German Health Minister was talking
about this a year ago and I think
um you know Jack pesobic was fact
checked for saying that this was
happening but it Avid actually was
happening and they say things like you
know the kind of restrictions that we
used for covid we can ask people to do
that to mitigate climate change we can
ask corporations to tell their workers
to work from home we can ask them not to
take business trips not to travel as
much as they would like to curb this
climate thing so yeah I mean they're
going to use these same methods over
again you know they're going to use it
for whatever new crisis they come up
with and what we see from the left what
we see from Democrats is a um
willingness and insistence to rule US
based on crises it's always a crisis I
want to insert the left it's just people
that are with their head down like
you're saying you know governments of
the Republicans that makes sense too but
I mean that's the that's the methodology
you know call it a crisis and then use
it to control and manipulate it let's
pull up the story let's tell the story
from Daily Mail
Biden will finally lift coveted
emergencies on May 11th after more than
three years White House urges 14-week
drawdown to deal with title 42 the
Border student loans and hospitals so
that's it he's finally putting an end to
the covid-19 National Emergency I mean
we've been I guess we've been out of the
pandemic for a while restrictions have
been lifted Biden said the pandemic was
over when he toured the Detroit Auto
Show in September right and then the
White House was like no it's not it's
not over it's over now he's ending it
it's it there it is he says the
emergency is over in four months
how are you copying you be sure I
thought it were an emergency no no the
emergency is over okay well it's a
14-week drawdown okay good that's what
it is it's totally stupid yeah according
to Biden the pandemic is over it ended
last year Well there we go everybody
congratulations we did it we can go back
to doing everything but you know what I
noticed um you know I I I I I love the
casino out here it's the uh the
Hollywood Casino
when we first moved out here craziest
thing
every table game had plexiglass like you
were talking about Matt they had got to
put the plexiglass and you weren't
allowed to touch any cards this is a
gambler's dream
because that means when you're playing a
table game but maybe you're playing uh
I'll tell you Mississippi uh you guys
are playing Mississippi Stud
here's how the game works dealer gives
you two cards there are three cards on
the board that everybody shares and you
gotta pay every time you want to see the
next card hoping that you get a good
enough hand to win your bet it's like if
you get a pair of jacks or better you
win you win money if you know what your
cards the cards your the other players
have your odds increase so you go to the
casino and then everybody's forced to
show their cards it's funny to me like I
don't I don't understand like you're
teaching a kid how to play that's how
you teach a kid to play somebody shows
I'm like all the gamblers right but
you're walking and you're looking down
you're like okay this guy's got a nice I
got a nice guy there's no ice on the
board I fold and so these these
businesses were complying with policies
that made no sense stopped nothing hurt
them substantially but everybody was
just for it but here's the point I want
to bring up aside from that insanity
they shut down large portions of the
casino
and they've never reopened them really
never why not and and I think for
whatever reason
nobody wants to work
so there's the there's a horse track
there and we went out uh not this
weekend but the previous weekend we went
to the horse races it's so much fun you
guys ever go to the horse races
yeah you you like they have a horse race
every 15 minutes and it's a minute long
thing but you get some food you get a
beer or whatever you bet a dollar on the
horse the silliest name and then you
hope it wins and then you win like a
dollar fifty or something maybe it's a
good time it's a good time it's fun it's
silly and uh but it's outdoor and so we
went there and it was funny because we
were there with uh Shane Cashman and
Nancy his wife and uh he bet on this one
horse called like what was it called
like American American prior or
something or American Patriot and when
we were looking at the horses going
around like they're doing the walk-up I
mean the warm-up his is going sideways
and like fighting he's like oh no it
came in last oh that's awesome we were
laughing my horse came in first I ended
up winning like 50 bucks but anyway
there's no restaurant you normally you'd
sit and eat food and watch the races
outside and that's so fun fun because
every 15 minutes the horses are running
and they said they really want to reopen
it but they can't find anybody nobody
wants it's the weirdest thing Man people
ask me that all the time too do you have
that issue at your restaurant they asked
me hey Matt is it is it difficult
finding people to work now and I'm like
yeah they're like why is it I'm like I
have no idea it's so weird I I wonder
that too like how is everybody feeding
their families how are people paying
their bills certainly not with eggs
where is this right where's this money
coming from that everybody has well
first of all it was it was ridiculous in
in the beginning of uh the pandemic to
pay people double what they were making
to work to sit at home how in the world
are is an employer going to get somebody
back to work come back to work for less
than you're making to sit at home who in
the right mind is going to agree to that
but the reason why people can't find
workers is um is is a question that
nobody is able to answer I have no idea
what are all these people doing I've
been asking this for for what a year now
brought it up on the show and the joke
is I mean I would say is when Sheamus
was here they got raptured where's
everybody where is everybody how is it
that we we we're still we still have a
shortage of workers nobody wants to work
but there's I mean well hold on Ian you
pointed this out a lot of homeless
people yeah a lot of them are on the
street I don't know the pro I don't have
proof that those that got fired from
their jobs are the ones on the street it
makes sense though even though they're
collecting unemployment and sitting in
their you know the one bedroom
unemployment unemployment gives out you
get like 18 months of unemployment I've
always been like sort of terrified to
not have a job I've been working
full-time like basically since I was 19
years old I don't know how else you're
supposed to exist like what are you
supposed to do I got unemployment two
years a lot of people seem to be doing
that that's a problem too they they said
like in 1984 they're like um football uh
alcohol and gambling are where are the
three like signs of the end of the
civilization especially gambling
football alcohol and gambling I think
those are the three that George Orwell
talks about was it you and Taylor are
with us right at MGM yeah Taylor won a
bunch of money and I lost 300 we went to
MGM National Harbor and Libby just lost
every hand and Taylor Southern was
Silverman was was with us and her first
hand she gets trips on three card poker
and one like a thousand dollars she was
like maybe I made your money back I'm
I'm pretty I have like a real aversion
to gambling it makes me really nervous
because it's so easy and fun but it's
that's the problem with it this is the
thing I think it's a an indicator there
are a lot of things an end of a society
or civilization the rampant expanse of
gambling and
you know look I I love the casino it's
fun it's like an adult arcade you never
go there think you're gonna win money
I'm not talking about going and being
like oh boy I'm gonna take my rent money
and bet it and then no no you don't do
that you get 100 bucks or whatever and
you say we're gonna just play some fun
games minimum bets just for the fun and
excitement then have some food and go
home it's like going to the arcade
you're spending 100 bucks on games no
different than if you went to an Arcane
put 100 bucks in your chip machine so
you can play tokens with your kids or
something but there are people like Mr
Beast who no but there are thousand
people's blindness right except I I go
to the casino and what do I see it's
people milking themselves dry I walk up
to the ATM and I see a receipt true
story I saw the receipt and I pulled it
out cause I'm curious like who are these
people betting all this money it's crazy
to me when I sit down I go to the crap
the craps table dice game people
probably don't know and I see a dude
standing there and he's got ten thousand
dollars and I'm like who the is this guy
to be gambling 10 grand like that so
crazy well
there's a they this I don't I don't know
if this casino is thought they have a
credit window but it's closed but like
National Harbor's got a credit room you
go in there people are gambling away
things they don't have I pulled I went
to the ATM and there was a receipt hang
and I picked I pulled it out and it said
withdraw 100 of it total available
balance negative 300. meaning yikes they
likely had just gotten paid
withdrew from their paycheck but their
account was previously negative so it
didn't roll over trying to win back the
fee that it's going to charge them for
taking it it's like seven six dollars
for the yep yep I don't I don't know but
I mean
I'm not a conspiracy theorist I don't uh
I don't buy into these conspiracy
theories but I do truly believe that the
uh the government at Large
they do not want to prosperous middle
class and that's evident and I I do
believe that uh one of I'm not saying
the reason for kovid was to kill small
businesses but I do believe that uh it's
one thing that did happen and and at the
very least the government saw it happen
and accelerated that process because uh
small businesses were act absolutely
just ravaged during the pandemic well
there was a thing early on and um I
think it was Lansing Michigan it was
like I think it was April of 2020 was it
April anyway it was like right early on
and a whole bunch of small business
owners went to the Capitol and Lansing
uh to protest Gretchen Whitmer and be
like hey you need to let us open up our
nail shops and our hair salons and all
of our little businesses you need to let
us open back up and Whitmer had allowed
casinos to stay open liquor shops to
stay open she allowed big box stores to
stay open and all the little shops had
closed so all these people showed up and
they did like a car protest essentially
and some people went into the capital
you know and they were armed
um they weren't like brandishing their
weapons around or anything like that but
they were armed and everybody freaked
out that these people were there and
they were like you're racist because
you're protesting these lockdown
measures and I remember distinctly there
was one woman who ran a nail shop and
she was like I have employees
I have a family I have a nail shop and
you took it from me like why did you do
this there was a hair shop in Texas and
she refused to close you know and she
kept it was shut down a woman in
Minnesota I think it was southern
Minnesota she had a coffee shop and she
refused that's right so they went after
her and she fled to Iowa I guess and
then the sheriffs came and arrested her
for illegally running a coffee shop yeah
you know as a restaurant tour I I
obviously I have a lot of kids working
for me you know minimum wage kids and
the minimum wage is going up to 15 bucks
in Virginia and you just cannot afford
that as a small business so I mean
you're more than doubling what the
minimum wage used to be so as a business
owner I have to I I've got to increase
my prices but as a restaurateur I can
only sell a burger for so much before
you say I'm not paying 20 bucks for a
burger I can only increase it so much
and so that what that does is it
eventually it destroys small businesses
because restaurants
that's the biggest industry as far as
small businesses go in America there was
a little barbecue stand uh not too far
from where we are it's uh where West
Virginia meets Virginia it's gone now I
don't I think someone stole it crazy
someone stole their their cooker and
drove off with it or something like that
and now there's and there wasn't the
waffle stand it's gone I don't know why
it's gone it's sad but we used to go
there and you'd go to the barbecue and I
remember one day we went there I took a
picture I posted on Instagram they said
they had no brisket the cost of beef was
too much yeah and I said well I mean can
you get it and they're like we can but
who's going to want to buy a 20 brisket
sandwich exactly and I was like yeah
I'll take the five dollar chicken
sandwich and and the thing is what
people don't don't realize and I mean
it's the most obvious thing to me is
that minimum wage more than doubles
right but did that person who's making
60 Grand a year
did his salary double no it didn't so
now when businesses have to double their
prices to keep up with the people that
they have to pay to work now you as the
middle wage earner the sixty thousand
dollar the 150 000 now you're poorer
so we lifted the minimum wage and now
the teenagers are getting paid a lot
more money but now you the person that
needs to take care of a family now you
are doing nothing but getting poor and
is killing the middle class and it's and
it's it's so obviously why should you be
paying a 15 an hour to some kid who
doesn't know how to do their job either
like why is that the thing this happens
with minimum minimum wage increases as
well as if it would happen with Ubi
you're a business and you have to pay
whether it's because by government
mandate or by by environmental pressures
15 bucks an hour you're raising your
prices end of story so for like Ubi you
tell everybody you get you get 500 bucks
per week guaranteed
then one day all of your employees quit
all of your all of your stalkers and
cashiers quit and you're like well why
are you quitting and they're like I get
500 bucks a week for for free why should
I work well how much do you want to work
man in order to compete with a free 500
you got to understand this we're not
just talking about the amount of money I
got at the end of the week we're talking
about the equation of how much work do I
have to do for how much reward
if the amount of work I have to do for
Ubi is fill out a form one time and then
I'm done we're talking about
500 per week for the rest of my life add
that up for one minute of work do you
think you're 40 hours of work for even
600 comes close sorry I the people are
going to say I would rather eat eat out
less but not have to work at all in
order if you're doing Ubi or for if you
know free 500 bucks or let's say it's
even 100 bucks
hundred bucks to a young person they're
gonna say 400 bucks a month I'll split
that money with my buddy we'll we'll get
a studio apartment and live for free and
then I'll figure out the rest but now I
don't have to have a job at all and if
you then say we'll give you a hundred
bucks a week if you do this job that way
you're getting twice as much they're
gonna be like yeah but I have the
minimum I need and I don't have to work
so I'm not going to say okay how about
200 bucks a week and they're gonna say
even that you want me to work 40 hours a
week and I or 30 hours a week whatever
okay
600 bucks a week and they'll say
I mean I guess
an exponential increase in the amount of
money you have to offer because you're
not actually offering them money you're
offering them 40 hours more work they
don't have to do yeah they're kind of
bankrupt not only the economy but it'll
bankrupt Society because there won't be
any innovation
who's who's all for these minimum wage
increases these big corporations the
ones that fund these politicians
campaigns well and that then they they
can put the small businesses out of
business exactly so Walmarts can afford
the 15. how can I right how can I
compete with with Walmart who a teenager
can just go there in stock shelves and
and by the way put their airpods in and
not have to deal with any customers and
listen to music while they're stalking
shows and make 18 bucks an hour and
Walmart can afford that because now they
have like a 50 reduction in Workforce
because they don't even need cashiers
anymore now you're the cashier I hate
that so much I hate that so I cannot
even tell you how much I hate
self-checkout oh my God like I have a
job and now I'm doing this and I was at
the thing the other day with my kid and
we like bought some stupid crap shelf
that then I had to build myself you know
because like I can't even buy anything
to put together and we put it on the I'm
like okay we have to try and get it on
the scanner you know it's this whole
undertaking of engineering product
project and we don't even realize that
there's like a glass sitting there that
I had already paid for a little
toothpaste Cup and the whole thing the
the Shelf smashes into the glass the
glass goes flying now everything is
smashed and now I have to clean up the
smash glass that I already paid for that
I can't even take home with the stupid
shelf oh I'm so mad I'm so mad I'm still
mad I got a solution for you I ate it so
much I got a solution for you check out
this uh this tweet from Wall Street
Silver on Twitter coming to a town near
you face scanning for Access oh I saw
this and public transportation it works
great as long as your social credit
score is high enough because you obey
fire and then there's another video I
don't know if you saw a tick tock where
a woman says she's paying her bills at
Whole Foods her check out with her Palm
chip for a bank account you go up to a
machine and you put your credit card in
it you then hold your hand over it and
it scans your hand and then you take
your card out and now your hand print is
is connected to your card no when you're
buying your groceries is that Whole
Foods I think it was you walk up and you
just hold your hand over the thing goes
and then you walk right out no I want
this not at all I don't want any piece
of this I recently I moved out of New
York and part of it was like I don't
want this encroaching you know
overtaking of my body and soul and mind
and identity to like go to all of this
stuff we're very close to New York to
having the thing where you put your hand
scanner on just to ride the subway
that's what it says no no have you seen
Minority Report no when uh you've never
seen Minority Report come on he walks
into really watch space movies and
stoner comedies and like yeah it's the
future he gets an eye he hits eye
implants
you know for I guess um your eyes they
recognize they can all the cameras
everywhere scan your eyes so he gets
them removed and gets other eyes put in
and then he like he walks into a mall
and it's like hello Mr Wong and then the
ads like because it's like Mr Wong's
eyes or whatever are all tailored to him
so you're walking around seeing things
man they'll be like hi Libby did you
pick up that new lipstick yet it's right
over here around the corner that's what
it's gonna be like they're doing this
facial recognition stuff
I went to a few years ago the uh it was
the the Amazon store I think it was in
in Seattle yeah where they have a store
yeah you walk in they walk out grab
whatever you want and walk right out and
the cameras track everything you do they
bought Whole Foods the plan is to
implement this at Whole Foods that's
what they're doing the hand Palm the the
Palm scanner thing the whole foods
during the pandemic I went in and I
tried to get them to make me a sandwich
and they said no they can't make me a
sandwich because of the stupid arbitrary
garbage rules and uh they were like no
but we have sandwiches made here and I
was like didn't you make those and
they're like yeah I'm like okay so you
can make a sandwich with your covid
germs wrap it up in plastic and put it
here
but and I could buy that but you can't
make a sandwich now and wrap it up in
plastic and hand it to me so that I have
the sandwich I want and the thing is
that no matter what else can
check it out and we won't stop can't
stop won't stop but the thing is that no
matter how bad you don't want it it's
gonna happen and the reason is people
are lazy awful and the problem with
Society is this is very simple the
problem with Society is we're too
comfortable
and people are willing to blindly comply
because they have AC they have heat
they're able to pay their bills they can
go grab a coffee from Starbucks when
they want and as long as they can do
those things they will gladly hand their
rights over to the government well I
gotta tell you man look look I know I'm
not a big fan of Starbucks well let's be
honest that pistachio cold brew cream
thing that's so good I haven't tried it
man I was thinking the other night that
you got to do uncomfortable things to
succeed and I thought no that's
backwards it's that if the things that
you need to do to succeed are
uncomfortable so you got to be willing
not everything that's uncomfortable is
going to make you succeed like don't
break your legs no I disagree I disagree
with someone with that you're you are
right but here's let me rephrase it
I think what happens to our society is
that what what used to be a rewarding
experience
people don't have to do and now hate
doing so for example exercise right
I like skating it feels good exercise is
is is is ancillary it's like it just so
happens that if you're skating you're
staying in shape but skating is fun yeah
there are a lot of people who like
working out because they're pushing
their limits and they're trying to get
more lift more weights but for a lot of
people most people working out sucks and
they're like I have to do something that
that's uncomfortable if I want to
succeed it's like it shouldn't be that
way it should be from when you're a kid
your parents take you out to go exercise
and it becomes a routine that you enjoy
doing that you push yourself and you
succeed at it and it feels good to do
those things you know what I mean it
used to be like biking is great
acquiring food used to be like that it
used to be a big deal when someone would
come back to the tribe with food yeah
that was like not expected if we don't
get it now it's like people loathe going
to the grill oh I don't want to do I
have to go all the way there to get the
thing like dude you are lucky I'm
watching 1883 and there's the scene
where the dad is hunting with the kid
and then he points there right the scope
at the deer and then he tells the kid to
look and then the kid's five and he says
you know pull the trick bigger and then
then he's like he brings the kid down
and he's like you did it you got your
first kill it's a deer it's gonna Feed
Us for weeks he's all excited and then
he's got to like gut it and pull out the
garbage and then throw on the horse and
bring it back orally carries it I think
well we you know what we don't even have
to go back to the 1800s I was actually
ironically just thinking about this
yesterday
and in the 90s you know in early 90s
when when I was growing up as a kid I
ate like
but when I joined the military at 17
years old I was 130 pounds why because
it wasn't as comfortable as it is today
to be in the house TV sucked you had to
get up and change the TV and everything
that you wanted to do if you wanted to
interact with your friends you had to go
outside we were it was so I truly
believe that of course food is an issue
I mean there's no doubt about that but I
believe the bigger issue is the
inactivity and and I think it proves it
because you know in the 90s we had a we
had the same foods that we had today and
uh and it was just as shitty but the
Obesity wasn't as rampant because we
were doing things we weren't sitting in
a dark room playing video games or
sitting at our phone and just our
friends are just at our disposal right
here on our phones we had to actually go
outside and interact with them you used
to have to go to the store to shop and
go to the bank to get money now I I
bought like 20 things on Amazon in the
last four or five days from my room I
didn't even leave the room I remember
when I was a kid I'd have to go run
errands with my stepmom like before the
weekend and one of the errands was
always to go get cash because you
couldn't get any cash at the weekend or
you'd have to like go to the grocery
store and cash a check you have to stand
in line with everybody else who forgot
to go to the bank on Friday before the
debit card I got my first debit there
was no ATM we had to like do a drive
through with like a little hydraulic
thing and you'd whatever you had to
interact with somebody cash a check to
get your money I mean I think you're
completely right that the lack of
socialization is driving this also the I
think that the opiates are heavily
involved with the lack of socialization
but oh no doubt about that I mean but
the bottom line is it goes back to we're
just way too comfortable in today's
society and uh and and the video that I
uh that I filmed live when those police
officers came into my restaurant and
stripped my livelihood from me
that's the message I was trying to get
across to them I was not ragging on
police I've always supported you know
police officers uh what I was telling
them is what they specifically were
doing was wrong and I don't give a damn
what your profession is if you're a
police officer if you're a teacher uh if
you're in the military if you're a small
business owner if you're complicit in
stripping a citizen of their
constitutional rights you are wrong but
they were willing to do it and and I
know for a fact
that at least one of those officers that
day felt bad about what he did because
he had a friend come into my restaurant
afterwards and tell me such
and uh
but the reason he did it is because what
because he didn't want to lose his job
because he he wanted to maintain his
benefits and he wanted to have a
paycheck coming in so he can provide for
his family and on one hand you ask
yourself well can you blame him but then
on the other hand the answer is well the
only reason this is going on is because
of people like him that are willing to
be complicit in things that are illegal
and unconstitutional to be comfortable
now if every police officer involved in
that situation would have stood up and
said this is unconstitutional I'm not
doing it then it wouldn't have happened
and and it was the same for me it would
have been way easier for me to comply
and just go along with uh what they were
telling me to do and I wouldn't have
lost you know six figures I wouldn't
have had the stress put on me in my
family that was put on me but there's
more there's things that are bigger than
you and there's things that are more
important than you and your business and
your money and my mindset was always if
I lose everything if everybody in this
entire country stands against me for
what I'm about to do and I lose it all
well I'm a hard worker I'll bust my ass
in in one way or another I'll provide
for my family and I'll be okay but if I
give up my freedoms I'll never get that
back and that's what I want people to
understand and remember next time is
that
if you re if you refuse to stand up and
fight for what's right just so you can
keep the the comfortability the
comfortability of uh of your daily life
then you're gonna lose something much
greater and those are your
constitutional rights and those are your
freedoms and and I just don't know how
to get that across to people but I hope
that my story and my situation I hope
that if nothing else what it proves is
that if you do stand up and you do fight
the people will rally behind you and you
can beat the government and you will
beat the government and and we are
bigger than the government we are
stronger than the government because we
are the government well and once you
give away your rights like that's your
kids rights too that's your
grandchildren's rights and that's the
most important thing you know then you
have to like fight a war to get them
back that's right yep and and I I did
this
I took on this fight mainly for my kids
and for the Next Generation because if
we don't
you and me if all of us here in this
room if if our generation doesn't step
up and and take this fight on right now
and not only take it on but when
and we just hand this fight over to the
next Generation by the time they're old
enough to fight this it'll be too far
gone will not be squashed already
exactly I got a feeling the next round
of shutdown government stuff is going to
be for power outages I could be wrong
what do you mean for power the grid goes
down for two weeks then our phones are
off people are trying to figure it out
the the government starts coming around
saying we're going to take control don't
leave the house don't leave the house
don't leave the house they're not going
to do that until they make us all have
electric cars they're going to wait till
we all have electric cars then we can't
go anywhere either I don't know if
they're gonna cause it or if it's just
gonna happen but if that's a situation
where it's like don't leave the house
don't leave the house what do we do or
do we resist again
literally how every single city was in
the during it's going to be asymmetrical
so next time it probably won't be a
virus next time it'll probably be
something a little they're calling it a
cyber cyber eleven yeah they're working
on that too like the FAA the flights
that all got grounded they're gonna they
could pull something well at the world
economic Forum they're referring to it
as a cyber pandemic or some kind of
cyber 911 incident that
it would wipe out everybody's money
right what are those things that would
like wipe out all of the information
temporarily
do you think that people should prepare
like realistically like I'm I've got
like a ham radio
um solar panels hey hey hey
everybody who listens to this show and
can or or figure out how to get chickens
is laughing right now listen to the show
because they got eggs and and their
neighbors are probably like please uh
might I borrow some eggs pancakes and
you're like no they're mine actually you
can have some no you're you're not wrong
you're absolutely right I mean being
being self-sustainable is the most
important thing but I'm telling you guys
right now and um
I hope this doesn't come across as two
politicians but I am running for office
right now but I am the furthest thing
even in this room from a politician man
but I'm telling you guys you need to you
need to start paying attention to State
politics these Federal elections are not
where you make your money it's at the
state level in Virginia in 2035
electric cars
are going to be the law so you are no
longer California too and New York so
Virginia and Oregon and Washington
exactly and I think it's Montana Wyoming
that said Wyoming said that they're
banning electric exactly electric cars
are banned yeah and so let me tell you
guys something that's where you're going
to move next a lot of people oh yeah I'm
not absolutely it's awesome it's
expensive though yeah it is the most
important thing guys the most important
thing by far and and even if you don't
believe that you know and we were
talking about this before the show even
if you don't believe that any election
was stolen or any of that elections are
not secure in the state of Virginia you
can go vote without showing an ID you
tell me how elections are secure when
you get that's true in New York too you
just sign for it oh hold on in what was
the story uh I think we talked about it
did we talk about it non-citizens can
vote oh yeah well in New York they put
up a proposal where non-citizens could
vote in local elections and it was uh
overturned they can vote right now I'm
going to tell you how and not a lot of
people know this so check this out in
the state of Virginia and in many other
states as well
uh as an illegal alien
as an illegal immigrant you can get a
driver's license at the DMV a valid
driver's license right so our voter
rolls they come from the DMV and they go
so how our voter rolls get handed down
Auto register right that's what happened
in California so check this out big
story a few years ago the people that
that run our voter rolls is an
organization called Eric e-r-i-c and
everybody look this up if you think I'm
bsing
e-r-i-c the electronic registration
information center Eric so what Eric
does is it reaches down to the DMVs and
it says Hey DMV we want all of your
information from all of your all of the
people in your state that are of legal
aids to vote so the DMV sends them all
that information now illegal immigrants
are in that batch because if you look in
the bylaws of Eric it doesn't hide it
from you it says in the bylaws of Eric
it says Hey DMV you are not allowed to
tell us who is the citizen who's not why
you I'll tell you why okay and so what
happens is Eric sifts through that
information it sends the the voter's
role the voter rolls down to the state
level and it says these are this is
everybody in your state that are allowed
that's allowed to vote and uh illegal
immigrants are included in that and the
answer to you as to why you know who
funded Eric who helped create Eric no
it's like a wild yes George soils George
Soros so George Soros is running your
elections and if you think any of that
is a lie please do the research we're
gonna go to Super Chat so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com click that join us
button over there and we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show coming up
for you in about an hour and 20 minutes
hour and a half or so Monday through
Thursday at 8pm but for now we will read
what you all have to say in those super
chats we got graph these as Peck the
like button buck buck greatly
appreciated greatly appreciated
all right moral objection says been
really quiet on timcast about the whole
Eliza blue situation you'd think real
journalists would want to know why
Twitter is censoring prominent content
creators on her behalf not only do we
have a journalist currently being funded
to go out and cover the story but um
well I mean I I guess I should I should
say that we quite literally have a guy
flying on a plane going to meet all the
people involved and interview to figure
out what's going on and do an
investigation of it and I gotta be
honest like everybody's like the
spamming the chat and spamming the Super
Chat demanding that we talk about this
one issue and it's just like I don't I
don't know if you guys follow the show
but we we've we we never cave like we
the the the pre-production isn't
dictated about with things in the chat
are like the hour before the show we
pull up all the stories we don't then
have a whole bunch of people start
chatting to us and then we say oh hey
let's let's throw out all the stories we
already planned for and then not have
anything pulled to talk about whatever
we don't do that so I'll tell you this
um know all about it
um Jeremy sent me some information on it
Jeremy was supposed to be on the show we
were going to have Jeremy Hambly on the
show
um today actually today true and uh he
just I guess I don't know exactly what
happened he didn't get back to Cassandra
uh who handles all the bookings for us
and then he didn't come I told him to
come on I was like I want to have you on
like this would be the perfect time
especially he was just reinstated he has
a big threat about what happened and I'm
like dude I'm not the person to to uh
like Jeremy come on the show like would
love I'm a fan I'm a friend uh want to
talk about coffee too but Jeremy didn't
make it out so I told him but you gotta
come on when you can so if everybody
wants to talk about it it's like my guys
let's get Jeremy to come on the show man
we want the quartering on the show but
uh so we sent Shane Cashman
uh so if uh we're hoping to get a sit
down with uh
anybody we can on whatever the story is
it is really interesting it is really
interesting to see all the details I
don't know enough about it um I just
know that there's there's something
going on here and that uh the quartering
a very prominent
um personality talking about culture and
news was suspended talking about this
video so I'm curious to see how it turns
out Simply put when I saw that everybody
wanted something done about it uh
I went and talked with Shane Cashman he
wants to do a full profile on on this
whole thing and I was like it's probably
the best and most effective thing we can
do
other than having Jeremy come on the
show so it's like I don't know what else
y'all want from me my friend yeah just
go dig into it yeah like Jeremy Jeremy
Jeremy come on the show and he can
literally say all of this we had a lies
on the show before all I know is she's
on Twitter she's a prominent activist
talking about the stuff many people are
saying that her her past is shady and
stuff like that it's not true she's
lying and I was like oh this is perfect
we're having Jeremy on the show and then
Jeremy didn't make it out and I hit him
mom I was like bro you're not coming
like come on the show so that's that's
the best thing I can do if you want to
see it talked about like
we gotta fly Jeremy out um what's
figured out and the challenge was this
was the day we had booked in a month in
advance and we're booked up but I would
I would happily make room for Jeremy I
mean you know did Britney venti get
unbanned on Twitter both of them did oh
good yeah all right let's read some more
Russell Garcia says I can't wait to vote
for Matt in the election sending love
from spotsy
well I appreciate that thank you so much
and uh if uh if anybody hasn't so far
you can you can you can follow this
journey because I'm telling you right
now I'm coming across the establishment
and I will with the support of you and
you can do so at Matt for VA on social
media and uh the website is matt4va.com
I'm fighting a war on two fronts
Democrats and uh these Republican
establishments so if you can help the
campaign out please do so yeah man plus
uh if you're not too far away go to
Gourmet man that was some good food we
got to come back down is that place lit
up right now from all the publicity oh
man I mean we've we've got such a an
awesome customer base man and uh and you
know it's it's now it's such a patriotic
customer base and the environment is
just it's awesome man there's there's uh
never any issues in there and we do
something every night so Wednesday
nights we do trivia Thursday karaoke
Friday and Saturday we do live music and
our live music so the entire name of the
restaurant is Gourmet 90s music bar and
Draft House so we're all about 90s music
and our live music on Friday and
Saturdays is uh 80s and 90s cover bands
so we blast out man we have a good time
maybe we can play a show some night
there man yes indeed what are your
signature Foods your top three meals oh
man so the uh the the the top ones are
we have a we have a melt called the
southern cookout and uh melts are you
know grilled sandwiches and uh so what's
in this one is uh sharp cheddar cheese
it's a really good sharp cheddar cheese
and uh sharp cheddar mac and cheese
barbecue pulled pork that we we do
everything from scratch so we even do
our barbecue from scratch and we don't
sweeten our barbecue sauce with uh sugar
that's good that's very sweeten it with
figs it's amazing it's amazing you got
the seed oils he did man I'm on board
I'm on board man society's at the point
where if you spend 30 to 40 more on the
ingredients you're gonna get 70 to 80
more customer Luke actually just chatted
ask him about seed oils
man he's all in he's all in
uh yeah man we went down there the the
food was it was amazing the pretzel
yeah it's crazy I mean like I don't want
to eat all these glutens man oh my God
which come down maybe not this weekend
but the next one will come yeah we've
got something for everybody so
everything on our menu we can do
gluten-free and uh our pretzels are
handmade uh by a guy locally he's uh
he's from Germany I mean the presses are
legit you tried it that was so good
we've got grilled cheese tacos so what
we do is we take a corn tortilla and we
grill shredded mozzarella cheese to the
outside because when you eat a a single
tortilla uh uh uh Taco it falls apart
right yeah all you got to do is lightly
grill a little bit of mozzarella cheese
to the outside of it and you're good to
go so that's what we do oh it's oh man
all right all right let's read some more
let's read some more all right what do
we got
um
let's see Wade nikunda says MTG reminds
me of a AAA gaming company nowadays oof
that's actually that is that is that is
a dig for those that don't know all
right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim the
cult twists everything we say to fit
their narrative then if they can't argue
against our claims they go right to
insults they're pathetic yep
that's right T-Rex patch up says Tim I
don't have the good stuff for Mr bocus
but I have UT supplements and treats
that help with Kidney Health I can get
the good stuff however on special order
requests what's the update of Mr bocus
you know you being here is the good
stuff man
uh bucko's doing fantastic he's sitting
I'm gonna go see him in about 20 minutes
say with zap and then I'm gonna come
back up for the after show he's probably
laying on my bathroom floor and I got a
nice big uh is he wearing his body fresh
no I got him a new collar but he didn't
like the body suit and he could chew
through it to get to the stitches so I
got him this this Cosmos collar where
it's like stars and stuff and it looks
like uh it's like it looks like a flower
so he can't bite his own stitches you
know uh eating a lot he gets inspired
when I get inspired so if I start
working out he gets inspired to start
eating a bunch of meat put on a pound
and a half in the last week or so has he
yeah he looks fantastic filling out I'm
gonna go take him to the vet tomorrow to
get some uh another diagnostic done
before we give him the stem cell
injection but those are coming and then
what's what's the what's the update uh
the stem cells they are ready uh that
stem is the company that does it it's
headquartered in San Diego California I
believe and they will be sending it out
overnight to the clinic whatever Clinic
we choose to go to and then they will
give them it's a real simple thing they
just give them the injections and I
think it's every three months he gets
another injection after that and they
think it will help his kidney function
that's the plan yeah that's the it'll
help everything yeah his heart uh I mean
I don't know exactly I don't know I
think it might even heal up his stitches
on his stomach I'm fascinated I I I
think it will I think that that uh they
you can buy stem cell therapy for humans
where they harvest it from umbilical
cords or whatever or you can do a thing
where they take it from you and then
culture it or whatever but uh we watched
a video about it and damaged tissue
releases releases some kind of chemical
or something and then stem cells are
attracted to it attach and then turn
into the cells around it repairing the
damage it's crazy you can do it with
teeth too there's experiments that you
can regrow uh stem cells for teeth yeah
he grows enamel but the um what's the
stuff underneath the enamel the tooth no
it's like the root but it's what's that
stuff not Dentin I'll pull it up I have
no idea all right you know what's crazy
though is one day like in 100 years from
now uh or like after all the stem cell
research and stuff uh like being
paralyzed is not even going to be a
thing anymore and they're going to look
back at us and laugh at us like can you
believe they allowed people to stay
paralyzed back then I didn't know people
used to drink Mercury yeah James
Stewart's figured out how to he injected
uh graphene Nano ribbons into a spine of
us of a mouse that had complete
Severance of the spine it was completely
broken in half and it regrew the spine
within two weeks it was walking again
wow within three weeks it was even
better all right Christina H says my
chickens have finally started laying
again it's been excellent we they never
stopped playing for us you can do some
tricks in the winter that you need a
light because if there's not enough
light the chicken stopped laying it's
how they but if you turn the light on
chicken chickens are not very smart
which may be surprising to you and they
think it's day so they keep laying it's
like a thing I guess for chickens
um but there's also some breeds that
will that will that lay better all
around and uh I think black stars are
really good layers yeah it's a road what
is it a Rhode Island red and rooster and
a barred Plymouth Rock we have a whole
bunch and we have too many of these guys
I like those little fluffy ones what are
those called little fluffy ones oh the
silkies
yeah they they have they they're meat
their skin is blue and they're and the
chicken meat is black that sounds awful
different serve different kinds of
chicken
you guys you you can tell the difference
between just a farm fresh egg and one
you get no joke I mean it's so different
it's crazy yeah when I when I go out to
eat and I order eggs I'm like these are
conventional garbage eggs because the
eggs I get on they're fluffy I don't
know they're just better the yolk is a
different color darker yeah it's got
more of an orange tint too yup yeah I'm
getting ready to get on the chicken
train man I'm getting some chickens oh
that's cool yeah I've seen restaurants
that have chicken coops on the roof and
stuff I've heard of stuff like that
heavy dope they like grow their own
vegetables on the roof maybe it was
all right Mac and says I was put on
Strattera at the age of five for ADHD I
was in foster care at the time later
when I was 14 I was put on Adderall and
Prozac I'm 23 now and I've been off
project for almost a year and I have
never felt better nice dude oh good glad
to hear man yeah that's where how do you
supplement I want to know I I because
for me sometimes if I if I'm addicted to
something eating a healthy thing kind of
like helps my body not just waiting for
the addiction to go away but actually
introducing new things kind of to take
control of my own body but I'm
interested to hear what you've done to
kick all that stuff yeah but you know
what I did man I uh so like during the
pandemic everybody was drinking more
everybody was like you know and I
started noticing man because I used to I
would I would have maybe a couple beers
on the weekend or something but you know
for whatever reason during the pandemic
may not have a beer day
and I said I gotta cut back man you know
what I did I introduced soda water
to get me away from you know just
drinking beer and it worked yeah yeah I
just started drinking soda water instead
of regular water and uh I didn't I
didn't want a beer anymore to cut back
on coffee because I'll do coffee with
peanut butter powder and a little bit of
coconut water I just start doing hot
water with peanut butter powder and it's
the peanut butter my body is totally
into it all right we got Mickey
Blackwell says I like this guy thanks
for fighting for this country overseas
and here we need to watch out for how
the government controls our food
well thanks brother I appreciate that
and you are absolutely correct about
that and that really scares me because
how do we really make sure the
government doesn't get involved in our
food that's the question are they
already involved in our food like yeah
but I mean you hear you you hear uh uh
you know a lot of uh I don't know if
they're rumors or not but you hear a lot
of stories about how uh they're gonna
come get these anti-vaxxers one way or
another they're gonna put the MRNA
vaccine in your food now and you know
it's just and nothing today to me is a
conspiracy theory everything's on the
table I mean the government's even
admitting the aliens are real now well
are they though okay but they did
release all those documents somebody
yeah they're saying UFOs like they're
like if they came out actually and said
yeah aliens are real I'd you know I I
suspect a false flag they're gonna be
like aliens are attacking everyone stay
inside do not get a gas car we need to
hold me electric your TV's gonna get
taken over like I just got a car maybe
two years ago my very first car ever in
my life and I will be damned if I'm
giving that up your TV is going to get
taken over and it's going to be an alien
being like humans we have come to take
over your planet unless you get rid of
your guest card to CNN we only have CNN
well those of us going to hang on to our
gas cars and fight back by keeping our
gas cars but then what happens when the
gas stations go away I don't like that
you don't have a choice we need to fight
back by putting the right people in
these political positions the issue too
though with the electric cars is that
they're not actually sustainable or
renewable or better because of the the
implications of the mining that goes
into creating those batteries the waste
from the batteries is worse than the
waste I think everybody knows that
except people who are lying to
themselves well I think they yeah I mean
you know these people who are like oh
I'm gonna give up my gas stove to get an
electric stove because it's better not
realizing that they're just creating
waste by getting rid of their existing
stove this is a good one from Jeff
Phillips's my background is pharmacology
and I've worked in and with the
pharmaceutical industry for years I
don't know one scientist at any
pharmaceutical company that want
anything except making medicines that
help and I'll tell you exactly what
happens the scientists are like yo we've
we've discovered this medicine that
seems to do this thing it's going to
help a whole lot of people let's put
into tests and then during those tests
they're like we noticed that these pills
you prescribe to save people from heart
attacks is giving them boners
and then a business guy goes we are
gonna make a fortune on boner pills
that's what it was wasn't it something
like that that Viagra was not initially
intended for that and ozempic yeah it
was like a diabetes thing now it's like
a weight loss drug right but it also it
will give you suicidal ideation oh
sempic will yeah but they have that
Happy song oh oh oh yeah but you have to
like listen for the whole thing because
it's actually pretty bad the side
effects are you know death I hate that
commercial so much I mean I believe the
scientists are really trying to do good
I mean the worker bees are trying to
solve a problem it's the same as the
military like US soldiers that go to
fight uh we we think we're fighting for
righteous cause we're fighting for
freedom in America in reality we're
fighting to the guy or the or the girl
to our right and left but in reality in
reality do we really know what's going
on do we really know what the puppets up
at the Pentagon or uh are really sending
us out to fight for it's the same thing
in the pharmaceutical company the
scientists the guys on the ground
they're trying they think they're doing
what's right but in all actuality
um somebody else is in control of that
all right David Flores says guys I spent
14 years addicted to opiates been clean
for four years now I was a fireman at
EMT no doctor told me no doctor told me
it was heroin I lost everything glad to
hear you're clean now my friend sorry to
hear you lost everything man that's
great dude
all right user 4179 says here's a few
bucks for all the 20s Ian's rolled
tonight hell yeah Ian's rolling twenties
like crazy Kevin Corbett says if you
like horse racing try your local dirt
track sprint cars and late models are
beastly
you know I really want them to reopen
the restaurant so you can sit up top
with a seat looking down and that sounds
fun eating food and then every time you
see the horses and you're like and you
can make your bet and then go sit down
and have your food and be like who got
it it was so much fun I bet on all the
favorites uh two weeks ago and all the
favorites won so it's like you you bet
10 bucks and you win like 13 or
something so it's like okay and I guess
it's because people will bet on the long
shot horses and then that money covers
so you don't you can't really you like
if you really want to make money
gambling you can go bet on roulette or
something put on a red or black but the
horse is fun it's like you pick the
horse with the stupidest name you know
like American Patriot or something no
offense I mean the horse was a nice
horse I'm sure but he just came in last
place so he didn't want anybody any
money or anything like that but it's fun
you know those those uh those jockeys
got some balls man yeah jumping up on
those horses man and going around the
track like they do man that's what first
thing I thought of when I was at a
racetrack for the first time I said good
Lord man these dudes they got some heart
man because those horses man they got
some power my favorite are always the
mystery shows that take place at the
horse races like you'll get like an
Agatha Christie show and it's all about
there's murder at the horse track and
someone was illegally doping a horse
those are always my favorite ones you
know Josh Karen says the Baby Boomers
retired during covid that's another good
point I've heard that a lot that's why
it's hard to find employ uh workers
because the Baby Boomers were working
you know management jobs they all retire
then the Millennials and gen xers start
moving up gen xers take over these jobs
Millennials you know move into higher
positions and now there's no low-skill
worker base I see what about all the Gen
Z people don't they are they just too
young still they're they're posting tick
tocks too much they can't have no idea
they don't know what's going on and
what's going on they're living out with
their parents probably
I guess my kid is Gen Z right is that
right yeah if he's too is it 10 is 2000
I don't know if that's gen Z that might
be gen Alpha it's like the next one it's
like the unknown no Johnny Alpha is the
next one okay I'm calling it Alpha gen
well that's what some people call it now
you want to look it up yeah now that
we've surpassed the Z gen Z we're
starting it over again now it's gonna be
Z gen Alpha gen beta gen
beta gen Alpha you know
you don't want to trigger a man you want
to be nice to those guys yeah you got
you should hear the piece of paper and
they walk on it and then you place it
that's what I do alpha generation as if
they're not going to be the most badass
humans ever man yeah I don't know about
that dude Jen alpha alpha gen is that
what it's called yeah they call it
Generations no creativity are gonna be
the Wall E hover chair morbidly obese
people if you say that they'll believe
you and then that's what they'll become
but we got to inspire outfits we gotta
change it man they're like what eight
what nine years
what's that what's what's the generation
Alpha early 2010s yeah yeah so I guess
that's my kid yep that's right yeah the
mid-2020s yeah all the kids these days
are gen Alpha well early 2010s what is
that is that 2010 specifically or
because maybe he's at the cutoff
oh it doesn't say he's uh Jen's Alpha
like I said yes he's like right on the
cusp yeah well Ian's a zenial I think
they call it
yeah the last year of X yeah I'm 79 so
right I'm right at the end of Gen X they
call it Millennials yeah when does
Millennials start Millennial 1981 I
think is it 81. it should be Millennial
Wikipedia says 81 to 96 is Millennial
wow and the 97 to 2012 is z so that'd be
2013. oh okay so easy yeah okay your kid
is he 2012. he's a zalpha okay yeah he
would be as Alpha
yep all right like what do we got here
James rice is a lot of people died from
covet and the homeless might be a reason
not enough workers that is a good point
you know yeah what's your um worker base
been like the whole process did you see
more people leave or have you hired more
yeah it's it's tougher to give people I
mean my wife and I
um are at the restaurant you know all
day every day be because uh it's hard to
get people in especially management
positions it's easier to get the the
younger workers that are just coming
into the workforce I mean although I
gotta you know I gotta overpay him to
work it's easier to get those folks
because they're just coming into the
work for Workforce but to get the the 25
year olds who can hold down the
restaurant without me having to be there
you know 24 7. those are the positions
that are impossible to feel right now
and it's just I have no idea why I have
no answer for it it's just weird
but what I do see is I do know a lot of
people are on unemployment because I put
those ads out and I'll get like 30
applications a week
and I'll call all of them in for an
interview and none of them will show up
wow they're just checking the mark
because they got to apply to a certain
amount of jobs oh my goodness to fill
out for unemployment and I actually I
called the unemployment office in
Virginia and I said hey guys this is
going on I just wanted to you know alert
you to it and uh and they they
transferred me to like five different
people because everybody said oh I don't
know I don't know what to do with that
information and I said no no I got this
person's name right here I wanted to let
you know if they're on unemployment I
called them in for an interview and I
I'm gonna I'll offer them a job
so just so you know if they're on
unemployment I will offer them a job and
they transfer me to like five different
people finally she's like we don't have
anybody that records that information or
but here's the issue if someone makes 20
bucks an hour loses their job goes on
unemployment comes to you and you say
I'll give you 15 bucks an hour and they
go okay and then you're like why aren't
they calling back they could be telling
unemployment I got an offer but it was
under my normal wage and they'll say no
no don't take it
because the the problem is if somebody
makes let's say somebody makes like 50k
a year and they get laid off and they're
desperate unemployment cover is a very
small amount then they get offered a job
at 35. what they actually say is if you
take that underpaying job you will start
like it will that your bills you'll be
able to pay them you will end up in the
exact same position and it'll be for
longer and it will reinstate another
round of benefits so the math actually
is don't take an underpaying job
otherwise they'll end up paying more
unemployment you see how it works yeah
or I do not that I'm saying it's
Justified I'm saying that's the logic
they give yeah I mean everything the
government puts their hands on
um turns to and that's the that's
the moral of the story that's the bottom
line yeah well you know that's that's
truth that's truth John L says what is
Libby's excuse for the post-millennial
headlines of antifa forest protesters
that was funny I got you you did yeah
you got me I was reading this post
Monday it was like antifa protests
shoots cop burns down buildings and I'm
like hold on a minute you know it was
interesting because we had run stories
about that before where the headline
called them domestic terrorists
um and this was the story that Andy no
was working on
um and he we he and I talked about it at
length and apparently it's actually
called the Atlanta Forest
um and he thought that by saying
Defenders
he was making fun of them well why would
you want to make fun of them yeah just
in the news we didn't end up totally
agreeing on that headline yeah even
Cassandra wrote a story and she called
him protesters and then I said the same
thing I was like timcast.com protest
what is this and then later that they're
charged with domestic terrorism and I'm
like let's just say our alleged domestic
terrorists our previous headlines had
said domestic terrorists yeah
um so I think maybe we were just
switching it up a little bit but alleged
is key it's just been charged but I
think they were changed they were
charged with domestic terrorism but the
guy that shot the cop in the woods yeah
then he got shot allegedly and and you
got he was allegedly killed yes well
he's dead and you can't defend the dead
but you got to understand the scariest
thing of the story about these
antivaterrists is that they crossed
state lines with guns you know that's
really a disconcerting situation I don't
think you should there should be
obviously checkpoints so that you're not
allowed to cross they cross state lines
with guns shout out to the United States
that's crazy
that's just
heavens
Mercy all right B Walsh says I was in
Walmart one night at about 8 30 p.m so
in a busy area not not so real late all
right so not real late they only had
self-checkout I forced them to put some
on a register said there's 20 employees
doing nothing
yo you know I can't stand we would go
what store would we go to we stopped
going there uh I think it's I think it's
Weiss the supermarket chain out here
because our soft Checker doesn't work
here's what happens I know what you're
going to say what what do you think I
hate it man so you you re you ring
something up you and then it tells you
put it in the bag exactly and then
you're like it's in the bag it's in the
bag it's like please Place item it is
it's sitting so you have to take it out
and put it back in exactly where would
they say every single just remove the
item from the bagging area and they're
like there's nothing there yeah I
literally didn't put anything and then
I'm going I'm putting it down and then
it's like I won't scan anything and I
pick it back up and it's like please
return the items and like I put it back
down and then it goes please wait for
assistance um are you kidding me and
then we're like hello is any human here
there's no humans nope I just want to
walk down the aisle and just push
everything onto the floor man it just
pisses me that's what they do in New
York and then they steal it they put
they put face masks on because you know
they're covered compliant walk in with
garbage bags take everything off the
shelves and run out and security guards
like nobody will stop them and you'll
even have employees telling customers
like don't do anything and they'll just
film comment but everything is becoming
automated I even get I I get an email
probably once a month from companies
that are making these robotic arms that
can run your grill for you
all right Stephen sounds like it's going
to result in good grilling Stephen
Sanders says Tim a lung cancer patient
and myself were arrested December 12
2022 with another veteran DeLand Florida
for not wearing a mask held in police
car three hours 47 minutes all charges
following SSA mask policy last month
footage available in Florida where's Rod
DeSantis on that one
big hail fences big fan Tim the fact
that this was allowed to happen is
absolutely disgusting wouldn't this
qualify as biological warfare when do we
bring back tarring and Feathering I
don't think tarring and Feathering is
actually effective not that I think
locking someone up for you know a long
period of time is effective either well
if you try and feather someone that's a
that's death you kill them by doing that
pretty much were they killing them yeah
you can you could die from that yeah oh
yeah yeah they used to do it all the
time to people that's a weird thing to
do I don't know they also used to draw
and quarter people that would also kill
have you guys okay so I'm watching 1883
I don't like it all right I don't know
you guys have seen it I haven't seen it
no everybody's telling me last night
then they're like you gotta see it it's
so good it's it's the Oregon Trail it's
just it's this it's a prequel to
Yellowstone and they're and they're
going and there's like it's like if
you've ever played the game of Oregon
Trail when you're a kid oh you're gonna
love it and then I'm watching it and
it's literally like every five seconds
it's people just killing each other and
I'm like come on man and then and then
it's apparently like it's it's realistic
to how things were back then I'm like
come on there's like a pickpocket and
then and maybe this is true fine the
main character just shoots him in the
back and then you and then everyone says
someone else pickpocket it starts
stomping on them while he's got like
buck shot in his back and then he goes
he took my wallet and grabs his wallet
back and then they literally drag him
and just string him up right there
killing him on the spot and I'm like for
real okay maybe maybe maybe then
there's like oh I don't want to spoil it
but there's like a big fight happens and
a kid dies so they go to the Marshalls
played by Billy Bob Thornton and he's
like well let's go and then he walks
into the saloon and then he goes he has
the guy's name and then he's like look I
boom shoots him shoots it shoots a guy
shoots a guy shoots a guy and he goes
are there any else and then he points
another guy and he walks up and shoots
him and I'm like come on that's just not
literally every 10 seconds someone's
dying and it's like how would human
civilization function right if this is
how it actually went down and people are
saying like that's really how it was
you'd walk into a saloon and just murder
10 people and walk away and nobody I
don't think that's the other thing too
is whenever you see these shows and a
whole bunch of people get killed no one
has any emotional reaction and I don't
think that's accurate either no people
vomiting and stuff like yeah you'd have
an emotional reaction you'd be like
freaked out if somebody walked into
where you were sitting and shot 10
people all right we're gonna read one
more here Jennifer Ramo says Matt for VA
Senate at mat for VA on all social media
platforms if you haven't already would
you kindly smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and become a member
over at timcast.com type in timcast.com
Click join us we are going to post I'll
be on the front page at about 11 pm a
members only uncensored segment from
this show that you haven't seen we're
going to record it right now so become a
member to support us we really do
appreciate you can follow the show at
timcastirl on all platforms follow us on
Instagram you can follow at timcast news
on Twitter one of our reporters got
attacked by some protester lightly it
wasn't crazy he like tried to steal his
camera or something and then just walked
off and you can follow me personally at
timcast Matt do you want to shout
anything out yeah absolutely please
follow me at map for VA everywhere uh
Twitter Facebook everywhere and also
check out my website matt4va.com and uh
and follow this journey I am on to like
I said crush the establishment and bring
some true patriotic representation for
the people to the state of Virginia so
uh so I can I can I can I can start to
clean this thing up guys because the
state level stuff is uh is uh it's where
it starts and even if you don't live in
Virginia it's important to you because
Virginia has always been a swing state
and the first thing I'm coming to do is
make sure we secure our elections so
what you guys will know is that the the
the politicians that are selected at the
federal level the congressmen and the
U.S senators that come out of Virginia
they will actually be selected by the
people once I take this state senate
seat so please go to matt4va.com and
support my campaign guys all right on
I'm Libby Emmons you can follow me at
Libby Emmons on Twitter and you can
check out thepostmillanyl.com anyone
wants clarification it's Matt for VA
it's for not the number but the word for
map for VA
good to see you manic looking forward to
spending some time at Gore mounts
playing a show I can't wait man I'm
ready for you guys to come down and rock
with me and Matt Gates when he was on we
were talking about blockchain backups
for voting to secure the actual votes
that's very interesting so if you and
Matt can never get in touch I think that
might be something we can start pushing
forward I would love to yeah great stuff
all right bye everyone I'm Ian cross and
happy to see you happy Monday take care
of yourself tonight
and I am at surge.com it's been a good
show really hoping you do well my friend
Matt it sounds like your head is in the
right place uh that was a good show
let's get the next one all right
everybody we will see you all over at
timcast.com in about an hour thanks for
hanging out cheers